You
Hello my sweet and wonderful harem it is I your priestess your woman of the cloth your
Wait a second. Why did my I
Don't know why my bits changed color because that wasn't a thing
I was brown earlier and now I'm not
Why are you pretty why would I not be British?
I'm always British. I don't know what you're you're speaking of
I do not know once you speak
Hold on. I'm going to remove
Um, you can't look look away
Look away. Well, I
Fix my outfit
Please hold
Um, but hello, how's it going?
I've had a stressful day, but it is what it is. I have fia next to me actually she's sitting on my desk
Well, she's not sitting she's kind of just you know chilling
um
She is
Doing okay
She was uh the doctor said she was worse than the last time this happened
Lady, what are you doing?
Where are you looking? Do you want water? Are you done with that?
Are you done? Are you done with this?
No, you're not. Yeah, why did you look away? Did you forget you had food there?
I'm feeding her on my desk right now. She's sitting in her bed and I have um
Her food propped up in front of her
Elevated and she's just munching on it because she hasn't eaten at all today. So I know she's hungy
Mortice
Yeah, pull for your baby indeed. Hi miwa. Hello. Yeah, she's she's gonna be okay
Um, if you're new here, uh, my cat has a very rare and unique, uh, audiomean disease and neuropathy
Neurological neuropathy
Uh disease that uh makes it so she's paralyzed from the neck down
Uh, this happens and it flares up sometimes. Uh, she seems to have had a flare up
Um, and it happened really fast. I don't know what caused it
Uh, but she's okay. We're on her. She's gonna be on steroids. I'm actually gonna give her her meds in just a second
Um, but she's a tough kitty
She's my she's my baby girl
She's my sweet woman
And uh, she is wonderful and she is a tough kid you might hear here you want some cat ASMR
I don't know if you can hear her. She might be too far away
Boomi can you mind your business? Boomi's like, oh, let me take your food. No, go away, bro
I'm cute
There we go
All right, I'm back
I don't know why it's funny because I just added it and re-added it and then I went back to brow
I don't know why that happened
It is I
You're a priestess. You're none
I was trying to find like a normal priest outfit, but I could only get this none outfit
So this is what you get
Here you go miss ma'am. You're not done yet. Finish your food. Finish. Finish your food
Um
This is somewhat reminiscent of a previous life
So odd so interesting
Very interesting
Um, I do be jiggling
They will smack me in the face. Uh, I can also just be like gone
Completely utterly removed can I have them back? Okay, there they are
Um
So we're gonna play faith, uh
I kind of already know about this. I won't lie to you. I have seen gameplay of this before
It's a great game. It terrifies me
Uh, I have never played it myself though. It's different from watching a little bit of gameplay versus, um
Oh, are you okay? You need to be burped. You good Fia? Good girl. Good burp. Good burp
Sorry, I'm burping my cat
Good burp
Yeah, lady. Oh, yeah. Okay. Hey, boomie. You can come finish us off. She's done with it. Oh, you're burping right here
That's all yours, bro
And what the shivity, uh, okay. Here's some water Fia. Here you go. I bet you're parched. Have a little bit of sippy sip
You got your girl
Perfect. There's sippy sip. Uh, this is a scary game
Um, it's a pixel horror game, which is pretty cool. It's very analog
Um, cat's burp. Yeah cat's burp
Um, cat burp. Yeah, it's a horror game with strong religious themes and you guys know
I like to play into my religious trauma
So I'm gonna dress up as a nun and we're just gonna, you know, play the faithy one holy trinity. Um, I have a shock collar
Uh, actually, I need to put it on right now
Hold on a moment
Um, the heart rate monitor is kind of being annoying. So I don't know if it's gonna work
So I might do like if you donate, um
I'll shock myself. I mean, I'll have a buzzing good time
Uh
Do nuns burp nuns don't burp. I'm a woman of the cloth. Why would you even presume to think
That I would
Do that. Oh wait. No, I didn't want
I need to tis tight
This is so annoying to put on with no one here. Well, me. Can you not sniff her ass when she's trying to drink water? That's really
inappropriate
Mister
I literally just gave you
He slipped my hand. I just gave you food
I literally just gave you feel you didn't even eat it
Stop trying to sniff her butt. I know she smells weird because she came back from the vet
But I think she would like her personal space, sir
That's how boomy be sometimes. Um
The shock is very like surprising. It like really does take you by surprise. I have the same one that emmy has I believe
Um, I think it's different from the one that, um
Strelny has
But I have that set up
um
Actually, you know what I should have done. I should have set this up to my ipad not my phone because I need my phone for tracking
It's fine. I just might go ventriloquist sometimes
um
The heart rate monitor is being really annoying. I have two heart rate monitors right now
I have the one that I purchased and I have the one
For my phone. I mean for my apple watch and it's not working
And it's kind of annoying I even updated it and all this stuff
Let me turn it off and turn it back on again because you know
That's what they always say to do. Um
So what I'm doing, where did the thing go?
I was using this thing called strawmow where you can connect in your, um
Heart rate to your apple watch and it should go but mine's just not connecting for some reason
And then the one for my chest like I have like an actual one of you. It's like
under my
holy
Embrace right now. Um, it's really tucked up in there
and
It's also just not being picked up by my phone and it's annoying. Sorry. I'm going to be ventriloquist for a second
Wait, is my
Where's my my mouth normal? I can't tell
I'm just smiling creepily at you
Yeah, I've been trying to connect it and it just doesn't want to do it. Wait, where's the manual where the manual go?
Here it is
Just got home after work. It's time for today's church service rested mortis mortis
Uh, dear sister. Yeah, I can't wait to play this. Nope. This is for my headphones. This is not for that
Fia, are you done with the water?
Are you done lady?
Are you done, ma'am?
I was gonna put the cat cam on but I also don't want you guys to feel bad
And be like wow, she's showing her like sickly cat. Wow. Um
And also, uh
Fia, are you oh, you need to be burped ma'am. I'm burping my cat again. Sorry
There you go
Good burp. Good burp. 10 out of 10 burp Fia. Did you still want more water?
No, okay, you're done. Cool. Um
Because it's also just kind of sad to look at her
I'm a lie to you
Like she's fine. It's just like depressing to see a cat that can't move. So I'm not gonna put you through that
Um
She's just chilling she's she she's big chilling. Um, I'm gonna move her and she might squeak
I want you to be comfy
Yeah, I know there. See now you're comfy and you can rest your head. Oh, perfect. Oh, perfect
You wouldn't mind seeing Fia's cute face. Yeah, I might show her for a second. Let me see
I need to hide myself though
I'm not wearing pants and let me put on better clothing
Uno momento
Let me take this off
Oh my god
Need better pants
I almost clicked stop streaming. Um, let me see
Is this even plugged in?
No, it's not
Where can I even plug this into? Let's look it in here
Ow
Will this work? I don't know. Sometimes I don't like plugging things in the front
I
Lure
Okay, hold on. Let me put this on my face again. So you guys I'm just not creepily staring at you
Properties
HD pro webcam c920 none of my
Things in the front work properly except when I need to charge something
So weird. Uh, let me throw this behind my
My discy. So I'll let you guys say I'm gonna say a quick hi to her. Oh, there she is
What the heck?
It worked then it didn't work
Well, you guys can see a little bit of my leg. I don't know what's up with that. Why did it?
She's just like the camera's not even working because I'm I'm standing right now and it just like froze
On his little goofy face and my leggy
My thickum thighs
I know at least I'm wearing live feel reaction
She's like I cannot be asked right now. Okay, let me try that again since it didn't seem to work from the front
Okay, let me not
I'm like, let me not accidentally talk to myself
She you be yeah, she's had a she's had an interesting day
What the
Can I refresh this oh there it is
That's funny
She just looks so angry
Yeah, she's like, I'm tired of this grandpa. Why do you have airplane ears?
Why do you have airplane ears miss lady? Hmm. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
She big eep. She big eep
She big eep
She senses you
Fia's used to being on my desk on camera because I used to have her all the time
Oh my god, this is like really reminiscent of like
My pl right now because I would have cat cam. Oh, hold on
She just looks angry unless you guys want to watch her sleep. Oh get a little tongue lick. Oh, you get a little
You get a little air lick right there. Man. Did you were trying to groom yourself? Did you need help?
Hmm. No, you seem fine
Oh, she's looking at her chops. Mm-hmm. It's because she had some good dinner
She had a little bit of salmon wet food because I treat my little girl
She the best baby
You look so goofy what's up with your ears, ma'am
But yeah, no, so uh, fia has like neuropathy as you can see lift her tail. She can't move it. Uh, she is
completely
paralyzed
Oh, that reminds me. I need to give her her meds
Me there, I know
Fia, I'm assuming you don't want people to see you take your medication. So I'm gonna turn off the camera for your dignity
You ain't
You need to see your mouth
You might squeak
Open up
Oh, you're so good
Me
She's like disgusting
disgusting
um, okay, let me
Grab I'm gonna have
a little text
Actually, let me do another text
Txt
Whoa, that's not it
Is that it nope
I will add new text cat cam text
Select font
Cat cam
It's not even doing the font
You bitch
Change the font whatever it's fine
It's good it's cool
Is your tongue sticking out?
I can't tell her mouth looks like it's partly open
Wait this is gonna bother me. Why is it doing this?
Oh, I made it super small with the frick. What the hell what is happening?
Bro, sometimes obs just confuses me
Immensely it's just like sorry you can only have aerial in nothing else. I apologize. Why is this blurred?
I don't get it. Why did it blur it?
Bro this looks like
What the frick just I'm just never mind
You guys understand it's a cat cam you guys get it you guys know
You guys know it girl your mouth is open. I'm like 99 sure
um
Is too big
She had again it's upside down. Was that it?
I don't know. I can't tell
I wanted a specific font and I can't even freaking use it like actually what the hell
Potato
Cat cam fear
Yeah
She has like a little bit of an overbite so she is kind of goofy looking but I love that about her
Um, don't worry. I'm not stressed. I just like thinks to be a certain way
Boy the mashems put diminished you um, let me see if I can get this
uh monitor to work because I'm kind of
The
That's like the most important thing like I would rather have the monitor work than the shock collar
And now my watch won't even turn on but how are you guys doing?
How long till boomy jumps up and tries to steal the show?
Um, he'll probably sit on fia in like 10 minutes. Where is he actually? Where did he's right behind me looking his pause
deviously
I
Yeah, I'm I was just like I need to stream like to take my mind off of it
I want to play a great game because this is a great game my watch won't turn on
Apple please
Apple I've done so much for you, please
Here we go
Um, actually, let me put a bed below my desk for me. I almost rolled over your freaking tail
Um, so he'll sleep on the bed if it's below my desk and he won't bother fia
Hi handsome
But yeah, it's been a day. Can you move? I don't want to roll over your tail, bro. Unless you want me to the fuck
Uh
I
Do I need to scan this QR code
Here's boomy. What did I say?
Why are you sniffing her freaking ear he might hiss at her because she smells weird
Because she was at the vet. I'm gonna move you. Can you give her some space?
Jesus like please leave me alone
Here comes the boy
Did I like
Because you need a coin to open it up. I put the battery in the battery is the right side
And it's just not recognizing the um
What should it called here? Let me take this off
It's not recognizing and hold on. I'm gonna take off the camera because I don't want to
Do something on accident. Um, is my door closed? Okay
We a little nice guy if you help groom her. Yeah, no, he'll just bite her he starts grooming her and then he bites her
Because he sucks
Okay, I'll just take this off
Um, where is the court boomie? Did you take my money?
Boomi took my money. I had a quarter on my desk and it's gone
Boomi took my quarter boomie. Where did you put my money? boomie
Boomi told my boomie you owe me. Oh my god
I had I literally had a coin here before I left
Boomi's a thief boomi's a menace. We all know this already. Boomi has committed war crimes. What are you doing dude?
He's sitting in the cat carrier that I brought home via in
And he's just staring at me. All right, let me get on the recorder
Gotta go to the change job, you know
So I can go to coin stop and get myself some mauve ropes
I was kidding. I don't smell. Let you guys get the joke. Okay
Do-do-do-do-do-do
Wait, she be a florida woman? No
If I was a florida woman things would be very bad. So I have so this is the thing. Hi fia fia's gonna be my vana white
um
And let me see maybe I like put the coin in wrong and that's why it's not popping up because it's supposed to be showing up
as like a certain name
when you go to um
It's not opening now
Oh when you go to
Oh my god, boomi. Hi. I don't need you here right now
I needs to be pressed in
Stay I feel like it's not going in all the way
But I get like a bum thing
Boomi has to sniff everything
I'm gonna burp in your face, dude. How about that? Oh
Boomi I blame you. I accidentally just dropped the coin battery
Boomi you menace. He's standing right next to me. You guys can't see
Thank you. How are you doing? Sweet Marcy
Everybody say hi to mercy if you haven't already. I'm sorry
I'm not looking too much at chat because I'm just stressing myself out by trying to fix
I was dealing with this before I like when stuff
Works before stream and then when I start stream it doesn't work. Don't you love that if you're a streamer
Or if you watch like a streamer
I
Scuff life truly, okay
Let me see if I can clip this back in without taking it off completely because I have the strap on me already
That sounds funny. You know, I stay strapped
Boomi can I help you?
He's like, let me help you mom. No, do not need your assistance nor do I desire it
You insolent and petulant child
That you have a strap on it
Oh mercy, oh mercy mercy mercy
Boomi has the funds. Okay, hold on you to lift up my shirt again
If this doesn't work, we will have an interesting time
Wait, did the don't know thing go away? Where the heck that disappeared? Hold on
If you guys don't know it didn't show up for whatever reason, let me check
I don't know why that was removed from this scene
This bunny knot wait, I'll strip
Oh
Tipped four dollars and 20 cents this bunny none is about to have me reading the bible have me reading the bible in all seriousness
Congrats and thank you. I hope I got me too. Me too
I'm gone with one bullet
Thank you sideswipe. Thank you anonymous. Thank you. Lionel con claras
For the five dollars to buy chat
Merci or uh, gracias
Okay, I fixed it. It says I have to wet it. I'll just wet it with my sweat
Yeah
Well, let me make this a little bigger, you know put it put it over here
I don't fucking know put it in the middle. Dang it. I shouldn't have sworn
We're back with fia on the cat camp fia. What's the weather?
My legs don't work. Okay. Anyways, uh back to you boomy with sports
Oh mercy. Oh, oh mercy. Oh mercy
Oh, oh my okay. Um, let me see if I can it can detect the heart rate monitor
Nothing wants to work
Besides this even the shock caller gave me some issues at first
I don't want to accidentally connect the heartbeat monitor. Somebody's fridge in my apartment building
Bluetooth and ant plus battery life 400 hours
Distance six meters strap adjustable
65 to 95 centimeters
This product is for sports purposes only it is not meant to replace any medical device
Turn on bluetooth settings toggle bluetooth to on position
Don't search device or pair on this page. Just turn on bluetooth and go to the app. My bluetooth is on
Refer to the where the heart rate monitor where heart rate monitor? Correctly. It's it's correct
Find and add the h6 in the ant ant device list. Where where is the ant device list?
I don't
I don't see that
Is that under here
All I see is my fridge in my apple tv and my ipad and my airpods
Speed
In my in my cat cam my other cat cam
Speed I am speed
Connect to my home pods
There's a lot of things that's called unnamed and I just want to connect with wait. Is this it?
Oh, I found it
Why did it take so long to show up? Oh
Oh, baby, it's working. Wait is the one of my the honestly the one of my watch would be easier to do because I just get a browser source and then it works
Okay, but it's showing my bpm. I'm very excited now. It's at 91
Um, I normally rest a little bit low, but when I'm streaming I bet I'm around 80 so
I'm usually like
severely
I remember one time my resting heart rate was like 56 and they're like, are you good? And I'm like, yeah
Okay, let me see if it works
Mm-hmm
Connect get connected for free at education connection
Okay, I was honestly betting on my watch working more than this one
Oh
Riefling raid
Hello
Hello reef lens. Did you lick the back of your heart rate monitor? Did you pull the plastic out? Yeah. No, I did
I just used my um other sweat though on my holy
under
bus sweat
I didn't have to lick it
Mine is a 91 we're working it's the 135 my heart rate being in a I'm trying to think
I think when I was about to get on a roller coaster
I was checking my apple watch one time and I was like just at 200 waiting in line
Because I was freaking out
Oh, but welcome reeflings. Welcome
Hi, we got fia on the cat cam. Do we do we do?
Um, she's even she's had a long day. I have the
Oh, I don't want to accidentally hit her in the face with it
I have the
Collar and I can't show you the heart rate monitor because it's on me right now
Uh, I only remember the girl is dancing
Let me hold on I need to put this back on myself because I took it off to put on a different outfit
Okay, since now that I know that it works on
Fia you look so freaking goofy right now, ma'am
Live reaction fia
Fia, what are you up to? What are you thinking?
Why do you just have airplane ears? She's just listening to me. Yeah
What is she looking at leave her alone she be
Um, yep, this still doesn't want to work. This app sucks. Okay, I give up. Um
How do I do the one on my chest then?
I'm so sorry
It's already been like 45 minutes and I'm still figuring stuff out, but I'm very glad you're here
I'm so thankful for you Haram
No thoughts only airplane
Okay turned on the monitor. Let me connect it to my
Maybe do
My twitter ai was not kidding around
Please ensure device is connected to bluetooth
Please ensure what?
Let's see let me do this that please please
Okay, I can turn this up a little bit
Whoa
Shoken in it
Okay, I think that's good. I think that's good for the lovely caller
I think I said it at a good thing because it'll give me gives me a little yelp. Um, what's my heart rate at right now?
Let me it's at 93. Um
Let me
Try to figure out how to add this too because like, uh, what is it the brand it's called
Something with a C
Every stream is happy. I'm half playing
You know, I just like I'm not like other streamers. I just like to talk the majority of the time
For good video games. Don't you just want to hear me out? I think you just want to hear me out. So
Sorry
Sorry, uh, oh
Um, boomi
Why are you like this?
You're gonna give her a smooch. She was waiting for a smooch. You didn't give it to her
Boomi, I swear if you knock the webcam
You're dead to me
Why are you? Oh, see you did take the quarter because you're trying to take this one
You thief you malicious thief
Is that a push push it is a push push. He's a push push. He's a thief someone stop him
highway robbery
The criminal mastermind
Okay, I'm gonna watch a quick youtube tutorial, but how to set this up. Um handsome boy. You need to move out the way
Oh
I knocked my
Excuse me controller into I mean nuns don't burp. You didn't hear that. I knocked my controller into the trash
Have you played this game before? Uh, sort of kind of I've watched gameplay of it, but I have not played it for myself
So we will see
Uh, so let me in three easy steps how to get heart rate monitor on stream. That's not what I want though
Uh stream
What's the app people use
I'll look at this random dude. I love people's thumbnails sometimes. They just look insane
I'm gonna turn off the desktop audio so you guys don't have to hear the trash
Oh, this guy is interesting looking
Yep
I have to get an app called pulsoid
What
Oh
Okay, well, I think I have to pay for that
Meladia reaction stream
Pulsoid wait
For the love of all that is holy
Please open the app store. I am begging you
Pulsoid is free. Okay. Okay. I got you. Got you. Got you. Thank you, mama. Thank you, mama. Thank y'all
If you could see like I'll me pretend I'm clacking my nails together
Thank y'all. Oh my god. Thank you queen. Sorry
I talked to Strani for like two hours this morning just just because
Everyone just like she just like wanted to ask me a quick question about something and then we just talked for two hours
It was great
I love that about us
Go to sleep. Good night. Yeah. Yeah, you've been up for a while. You've been up for a very long time
Hi, Strani
Uh pulsoid
Get
You
Mommy voice
I don't even call it my mommy voice anymore. I just call it my patreon voice
Hello, I said all I do is I talk slower and I'm more breathy
Do do do I have to sign up? Oh
Oh
Don't have an account. Strani. Just give me your account. Wake up. Give me your account
Get started for free
What is this bro?
Ah what the frick am I looking at?
I just want the default
Just give me the default
Zaddy, please give me the default. What the frick is this ad?
Oh, this is on like a totally thing website. I can't copy this from my phone
Hold on
Here let me
Do
Hi, how's it going boo? How are you doing?
I'll sign up with email
Nope type that wrong
You want me to give you my channel link
No
I
Do a captcha guys. I hate this
Via under cat camfo today
Oh my god, it's the wrong password
No
What is the password? I just made one earlier because I forgot I did already sign up for this. Um
I'm gonna kill one more. I won't kill one you add
Hi, my name is chibi cotton bum and welcome to the struggle bus. That's for sure
My tommy hort is your tommy hort. Oh, I did one of those
Freakin huge long passwords. Okay
K
I bet there has been a actual
Streamer that just like accidentally said their entire password
Out loud and thought they were like muted or something
What it says it doesn't exist
Hello
Does it have caps lock on
at kozame
Oh, I see what I did
I would suck at that one password game. I'm just telling you that right now
Hey, at least I was on time for my stream though. Yes, I didn't tweet it out because I wanted to spite that one person
That said I need to tweet it out
Okay, I already got a I have to install an application
Bro, I'm literally gonna commit but it's fine. I have an excuse
I have an excuse
I was taking care of my daughter
My lovely daughter. Okay
Autism or autism spectrum disorder what?
Does she we go through heat cycles like what are you asking?
What are these gray names doing?
It's more fun than
That
I was reading it out loud at first because I thought it said does she be like bunnies?
And I was totally wrong and where that was going. Uh, I already have a heart rate monitor
Configure configure I want a cool pixelated font
I
Can't find a pixelated font
Oh my god
What noi noi
I had a lot of gamer subs today
Oh, yeah, yep
I like this one
I like that one. That one looks good. I like a lake. I like it like a lot
Um, what color should I do? I think I like this color. No, wait. No, that's not the right color
I didn't want it that one that one right there. No, that looks too brown
That's fine. Okay. That's cool. That's good save settings
copy
Oh, what's this? How do I connect it though?
How do I connect it to my heart rate monitor?
Oh, what the hell?
I'll thank you for the fine gift it more again
Oh my god, thank you
Try to dongle. I'm gonna eat your booty hole right now, boy
Turn your take off your pants and pull your pants down on me eat that booty hole
Hello
Hello. Oh, thank you. Lover of fandom aptly named for the five gifted. Why are you awake still go to bed strongy
The app should detect the heart rate. Well, I didn't download it to my phone yet. I downloaded it
To my it won't oh my god. I'm getting like cramps and it's pissing me off. Um, that's also why I'm a little like
Or is it what what is this?
What was this then?
Uh, just get rid of that real quickly like
Okay
Fiat, why are you facing?
Look how she's sleeping
With this heart rate monitor, I'm fucking coming to your house. It will be faster. It probably would
Uh, oh no strongy's gonna come and clap my arse. No, I don't want it or do I?
Can you breathe, ma'am?
Oh
I'm sorry. It's kind of funny just to look at her just like face planted. Um, okay. I think configure
Oh, I don't want that
Is it showing up? I can't see it
It's not even showing up
It's not even like the preview is not even showing up
Please
I'm like demoing it and it's not working launch
What?
Fiat is cute. Fiat always be, you know, cute
You know
You want it
Whoa
Poker's in the chat. Hold on. What the hell?
What do you do absolute mad lat? Can we get some dubs in the chat for this bro right here?
Holy crap
50 gifted my god
Jesus manifesting we're manifesting as the stream starts
Thank you so
Hold on. Thank you so much stash power for the 15 gifted
And thank you for the don't know
a grandson tip
Is your name
Praise be did that one dude get gifted yet? Is he just stuck like that?
Whoa, I was confused because I thought of zero was in the chat, but if someone also called a zero buy a zero
Boomi are you eating litter boomi boomi stop
Boomi
King of umashu stop. What are you eating? Can you not?
It's oh, where did you get this?
Found a rubber band. I don't even know where you have rubber bands
Okay, now it's saying it wants me to download the pulsoid app on my watch instead of this heart rate monitor because I can't detect the heart rate monitor
Uh, right. No frick. I'm trying not to burp. I'm trying to mute it. It's not working
Bro, nothing is working
Okay, okay, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. Uh, I'm gonna go to the watch app
I'm gonna I'm gonna go to get down on it. I don't know but uh, yeah
Mm-hmm
Oh, now I know why it wasn't working
Because I didn't allow it to connect to my health data. Oh lord
Okay, oh wow look there it is
Sorry, I'm so sorry
Oh
My god, finally, I'm gonna put it right next to fear. No, this is a terrible font
Can I put a background on this? Can I
Is there
Hey cb, up is it's live want to say hi hi jackson. Thank you for the stupid jackson. Thank you. Thank you very much
It's all the background would be good. Yeah, it would be good too bad. I can't freaking do that
How about
I'm just gonna put it on my
Well, I don't know why I'm doing that but I am it's going on my head
Because that's how it be yeah, that's how it be
I'ma be I'ma be I'ma I'ma I'ma be
Bitch, baby. What what I'ma I'ma be
The shit baby. Check me out. I'ma I'ma be on top never stop
Why is it I wanted to change it to a heart because I can't really see the line that well
Nope, it doesn't want to be a heart
Okay, I think we're fine
I don't really care anymore if it's not going to turn into a heart or not you guys see that right
Okay
ow
I'm taking this off
Because it's hurting my chest
It doesn't work anyways
I'll use this when I work out for realsies though because it's good to have although I have a watch so
had I known
That I could use my watch as a heart rate monitor. Well, I already knew that but I didn't know I could connect it
Then I wouldn't have bought this. I can't get this off and boomi's coming. No
Oh my god, oh my god, boomi, please boomi boomi, please. Oh my god, boomi, please
I'm so scared. You're gonna knock over my webcam. You've already you're sitting on fia. You're sitting on fia
Brother, brother, there's nothing for you here, brother, brother, please
Okay, anyways, um, so what should did you just
What are you?
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. I'm really blocking the camera with my hand in case he knocks it down
What is on your nose
What are you eating? What are you eating? Get down
Go, what are you eating?
Yeah, fia doesn't give a shit. She's like, let me sleep, bro
Oh my little girl
Yeah, I'm sorry, boomi's sitting on you. Yeah
Um, where's the squirt bottle because you're being too much. Where is it? Where is it? Where is it?
Yes
Get off the mother
No
Yeah, you better run, bro. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Get your ass back home
Get your ass back home back home
You literally have so much wet food right there. You didn't even eat it
You literally just want to steal fia's food. What is wrong with you? Where's rena rena? Where I have not even seen rena
Ma'am
It's rena
Where are you? I have not seen you
All right, okay
It's good
Boomi, here's a toy. Here's a toy. Take it. Take it
All right, I need more water
Oh my heart rate is rising. Okay. Um, so what should be, uh
The like when I get shocked thing being like what what number should I be at to get shocked?
So because that's that's up to you guys
Or you can if you donate
If you donate at least
$10
To the fia fund
You may shock me
with love
and affection
I should have asked how Emmy did this
Sorry, I'm making myself some gambersops
I'm addicted to it. I was just so good
Oh
This peach lemonade lean flavor is so bomb
And I like you guys know I suck at drinking water, so excuse me boomi get out of the way
Do you want an ice cube here have a nice cube
cold hearted
murderer, I bet boomi's a burger or something
Why are you eating off the floor? That's not an ice cube. That's a piece of litter
Oh, this is gonna spill. Oh, it's spilled
Oh
Nice I'm walking around the shock collar my neck like a freak
Hello my dear
Oh
Throw that away all right seven or so it's been
An hour and I have not started the game
Uh
And that's why I don't tweet out that I'm streaming yet because I haven't even started the game
One hour in maybe we can start in 15 minutes. Okay, wait, what did you guys say?
100 125
Okay, let's like see what happens when I actually get scared
Um, I don't know how long that will take. I don't think it takes that long, uh
But yeah
Okay, we're good. We're good. We're good. I think we're ready to rumble kiddos. I think we're ready to freaking rumble
Put this on my freaking head. Um, I don't want to take up too much space
Yeah
Put it right on my bang
Yeah, you even your eyes are open. You're not even
Well, you know screech
She was like looking my hand on the car right home. It was really cute
Okay, let's turn on the
Yep
Yep, okay now i'm on a tweet
See now i'm gonna tweet now i'm gonna tweet
Who messaged me
Artist
Art
Okay, anyways, I'll respond to that later time to tweet that I'm like
I wonder if that there was one person that was just like I will tweet for you
I'll tweet when you're alive and I'm like
I feel like you'll forget and I'm pretty sure they've been forgetting so it's not just me
It's not my fault. Uh, it's the universe's fault. They just don't want me to announce that I'm streaming on time
So
Okay, let me retweet that to my old
Oh freak
All right
Now we'll shake our body gotta do that conga
How do I play this?
Why is it there twice 13 dollars and 37 cents we need to test the shocks
So I have it set to this setting because I'm the little devil caller
I haven't set to this setting called tremble, but I have the tremble
I like it kind of like as a wave like I was like like that and then when I press it
Hello, I'm scared did it disconnect did disconnect I can't tell
Try and look in the reflection of my monitors
Hello
I don't want to like accidentally send like a
Okay, it works
It was very delayed
Oh
Was that sound I made I don't know it like doesn't work every time I press it though, which is kind of weird
I don't get that go. Oh, okay. No, that has to be a little bit
Oh that feels real weird
Oh
Actually kind of like that
Okay, there you go. You got some shots
I wish there was a thing that I could show that like I've been shocked
Like a toggle I could be like
Ah
All right, let me turn up turn up the music but why is it there twice? Why is the don't know twice?
I'm removing it
As you know understand I don't get it
Thank you for the don't know to put me in misery or pleasure doctor p
Oh, oh she oh ma'am. What's up?
Hold on. Let me I think she wants to be flipped give me a second
Here you go. You want to where do you want to go? Did you want to be flipped on your other side here? I got you
She might squeak, but don't worry. She's not in pain or anything. She just squeaks when I move her
Yeah, where are you trying to go?
Here I flip you yeah, I flip you I flip you like a the pizza
You need to use the bathroom man
Are you big chilling?
Why don't you tuck your head in I don't know are you could you just be a little cinnamon roll right now if you wanted?
Uh
The baby has been flipped. What is that? How is it the child?
Show me the child. I'm trying to do that actor's voice
The baby has been flipped
The baby
Has been flipped
Who is touching the child? Okay, do I have to play this with keyboard?
Oh, everything's in latin
There's a lot
There's flashlight mode. What does that mean?
Oh, I have to unlock them. Okay
So
The hell
Where's my game sound
Is there any game sound am I playing slender
Come on, let me
Okay, I'm over here now because I realize I'm looking in the wrong direction
But how do I how do I pick stuff up?
I turned off desktop audio. No, it's back on. I just can't hear anything either
Why is my life like this?
Oh
Yeah, no shit, there's no game sound you fools
How do I oh
Have you forgotten already this forest has a mind of its own if you get lost you could always try remembering where you've been
Pressing the escape key or start button is a good place to start
Okay
And any is this supposed to be game sound is it supposed to be is there bro
Oh my god, boomie I'm really gonna cry
Switch into headphones
I switched into headphones fuck of these headphones
You just did you just come out of the litter box
And you hopped up on my desk with your litter paws and you just got litter on me. Oh my freaking god. That's disgusting. You're so gross
You literally he literally just left paw prints on my freaking uh, what you gonna call it? Uh
mouse pad
I don't know if you can hear him in the background. He's now yelling
Oh
I hear it
Yay
I was lurking for a bit, but I broke broke it because he had my sympathy. I hope cleaning
I don't know why he's like this
Chad is doing this weird thing hold on let me fix this ten dollars can help fun. No
Don't worry about that. I don't know who that was
Ten dollars can help
Make a my way downtown walking fast faces louder
Oh, look a well would be a shame if I fell into it. What are you doing separate? Well, well, well
Well, do we have here?
Well, well, I can't interact with it. Oh
What the I exercised the well
Take no, no, I got a shock of myself
Ah
Is it too loud guys?
It's good. Okay, perfect sounds. Okay, perfect. Okay, let me take a sip get away from me boomie
Stay away from me. He just licked my hand
Okay
Ew
You're invited come celebrate Nate and Jason's sixth birthday Saturday, May 3rd 12 p.m. To 4 p.m. Directions turn right at 1
338 Snake Meadow Hill Road and go straight past the well
Was there a road supposed to be here?
What are you doing
All right
I have a high pain tolerance guys, maybe okay, maybe I should put it up a little bit more hold on
Let me test it. I'll give you a free shock
Yeah, I'm gonna put up a little bit more because that didn't even affect me
I'm stone cold. It's called this level is called passion
Okay, I think that's the right one
That's the right one
Me and the woods looking for a meal for real though
Oh, what do we have? You know, I'm gonna do some exploring before I into the house. I feel like there's more to see
Let's go see what that deer is. Oh, hello
What we have here
Goodbye
Mr. Martin
It has taken longer than expected registering the markers on your property as a historical cemetery
Our officers had difficulty identifying who was buried there the inscriptions on the gravestones are written in a language
That we cannot identify. I've sent the gravestone rubbings to that some of my peers the university of Connecticut
Connecticut
I will reach out to you when I get a response from them all the best jaryl hunderson
Say hello to the Connecticut Historical Society. Am I in Connecticut?
Excuse me. Can I, can I escape?
How do I get out of here? It's not letting me out
Oh
I didn't scroll all the way down apparently
Wait, I'm a little big. Let me just
Oh, no, I moved my mole. Don't worry about that. It's not fake. I swear
Making my way downtown
Walking fast
Faces past and I'm a nun now
What is then
No
Nothing for that
Oh sir, sir, I need to talk to you about our lord and savior jesus christ sir, please
Split please, please. Hello
Please take these pamphlets
Hold on. I want to go talk to that deer. Hey, excuse me. Oh dear
Hello
Oh
The Motton's house, oh, I'll just read this in my normal voice
The Martin's house lies about 100 yards off of snake meadow hill road. There's almost no driveway trees jut out and I need to sneeze
Okay
Trees jut out in the middle of a gravel path that is mostly covered in grass
It was difficult to find the house, especially since it was already dark when we arrived
father
Alred seemed to know where he was going. He simply drove straight ahead until we arrived at the house
I'm heading
Sorry in the headlights. This is the hardest font to read. I saw an old shed off the right of the path
Father already explained that he would rather perform the exorcism away from the house
But the martins had insisted that Amy remain inside
He complained that having the family present makes it difficult to proceed with the elements of the right that may seem harsh to the lay person
Cool, uh, I don't trust that shed
Thank you. Sorry. I'm walking into a tree because you just distracted me
Oh
Oh, I've got a bone to pick with you
this looks like the
remnants of that uh
Spidery thingy that was like
Hello, dear
Hello, how are you?
Oh, I'm gonna follow you then
Oh the children
The children and the deer can I run? No, can I run? I can't run. Can I can I can I
Can I crit book? No, can you freaking kids stop running around?
Are you just leading me back to the shed?
I should trust the shed. All right. I'll trust the shed. It seems like the kids are leading me to the shed
Hello
I don't like that the music stopped
Holala, oh
Mortis
Mortis, I love that
All right, well, I have to get that key
No, I don't need to read that. Can I, can I like...
Can I like walk a little bit fat? Like I love my gait. I'm just like...
That wasn't that I have a foal. What's up with that then?
Hmm? Hmm?
My heart really sounds spinning when you die.
Oh, that was rude of you to say. I was gonna come check on you.
Get cleansed by the power of Christ! Get cleansed. Get cleansed, bro. Get cleansed so hard. Oh, hello.
Oh, I gotta go. Sorry.
Oh, does it like randomize? Or did I just keep going straight the first time?
Oh, come on, dude. I was busy that day. Come on, bro.
This might take a while. It's a fox. Oh!
Oh, chaos reigns. I reign?
Stop! You shut your little goofy-looking rake mouth.
I like how you guys just all say mortis. Oh, hello again.
This rocks around you this time. Hello.
Chaos reigns. I love the voice acting.
Chaos reigns. Well, obviously it's not voice acting, but
I'm waiting for that. I was about to say that really random, like the worst way.
I'm like, I'm waiting for that white dude to pop out and start chasing me.
Oh.
Come on. Why is he so... Can I run?
Well, how do I run? Oh, wait. Do I need to press the space bar?
Oh, do I need to... Do I need to like compel him? Do I need to the pyre of Christ?
I know it's not voice acting. It's just... Okay. That makes a lot more sense, guys.
That makes a lot more sense.
I'm ready for you, white man. Come at me, white man.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, power of Christ compels this fat ass. That's all I'm saying.
Thank you. Yeah, this is what they taught me in non-school, guys.
They defeat him by having faith. Faith in my...
Bang and bod.
Crick off. Oh, you're going after the deer. That's too bad.
Sorry, deer. Okay, I already came over here. Do I need to redo stuff again? I highly doubt it.
But I'm in the shed. Will it make him go away?
No, you suffer.
You little gangly rake dude.
Gangly rake dude.
The voice is made using the software automatic mouth.
I took you three tries to figure that out. Listen.
Listen, okay. As they say in Smash Mouth, all stars. I ain't the sharpest tool in the shed.
I'm not the brightest crown in the box. All right.
I'm a little slow. Where the frick is the shed, bro?
Fia fun jump scare. No.
Okay, okay, okay. Hold on. Must be shocked. No, no, no, no.
I was shocking.
I was shocking as I died.
Oh, no. Boomi, get out of the trap.
You dingle. I think I drive a Corolla. I definitely drive a Toyota Corolla with a sick spoiler.
Come here, little boys. Tell me, what is, have you spoken about the Lord?
Can you say praise Jesus? I don't understand.
It's okay to make you more good.
Can he?
I like this game a lot so far.
Suffer.
What?
What did you say?
What did he just say to me? He sounded, he said he's something and I'll do her.
His back seating allowed if I ask for help.
I caught some people walking through the woods around the house last week,
not kids, just regular adults. They told me they got lost while hiking.
I pointed them back toward the road. The whole thing just didn't feel right.
I think I should go dig up Bob's rifle out of the storage.
Others, I thought they were going to say I should go dig up Bob's grave.
He said corruption, that about my father. Oh, I thought you said I'm going to fuck your mother.
Boomi, back off, dude. He keeps trying to jump up on my desk and chew on things.
I literally, he's probably like, you haven't spilled time with me all day. All right.
I'm prepared.
What?
What a beautiful day in the forest. Such a beautiful day in the neighborhood.
Justice for...
Rawr, rawr, rawr, XD.
Oh, worship me.
Dude, I'm just trying to explore this beautiful. Oh my God, stop. You're doing too much.
I'm not interested in you. You got to back off.
Like, he looks so goofy when he walks. Nice.
Whoa. Bob, the kids and I miss you more every day. The twins and Amy have started their next
school year here at home. Amy keeps asking when she's going to be allowed to go to the
real school. I think she's getting cabin fever.
Oh, dang. They're getting homeschooled. That sucks.
The twins are having no problems occupying their time.
Yesterday, they came in with their hands covered in blood.
Okay. I like how she's like, says it so casually.
Sorry, I had to mute my burp.
I guess they found a dead deer and thought it would be a good idea to touch it.
I think we might have a coyote problem because when I went out with them to look at the dead
deer, it was a pretty gruesome sight. I guess they found. You should just say they did find
because they found it. You saw a boomy get off my desk. Oh my God, boomy.
Boomy please. Look at this man. Look at this man.
All this just a day after the twins' birthday party.
Can't wait till you come home. Are they dead? They're dead, aren't they?
These kids are dead. They're deader than dead.
How did I? I've been going to the right this entire time. How did I circle back around? Okay, well,
you know, where are you? Where are you, white boy?
Show yourself, white boy. I found you, white man.
Lost in the woods. I thought I could find a way out any day now. I take a left. I take a right.
I take a step. I see the light.
I'm going to bang my head against the desk. I can't even get past this. This is like the tutorial.
Oh, nifty.
Oh, I didn't mean to go back in there.
Mortis.
He said something about inverted cross, power of inverted cross. I don't know, Spanish. You mean
Latin? When you got bars? It's actually from like a like a Zelda thing.
Oh, sorry. I'm in a tree.
Do you say I have the body of a pig? Who's being hung in this house? Come on now.
Enter the house once again. Is this a flashback?
Why is there only Amy in this, the family in the picture? Mr. and Mrs. Martin greeted us at
the front porch. Mr. Martin led us downstairs to the basement, explaining that Amy was down
there in restraints. I felt for him. There was guilt and shame in his voice. Amy was in the very
back of the attic in a chair downstairs to the basement. Amy was in the back of the attic in a
chair. Okay, are we in the attic or the basement? I'm confused. I'm sorry. I'm stuck on that perfectly
calm staring at us. It is hard to describe the look on her face. It was not the kind of look a child
gives you. Should be confused. I should be. That's the question. Interesting. Oh.
I'm lost spirits in this house. Oh, what a beautiful family.
Anything in the clock? The power of cars compels you. Is there a dude? Oh, that's probably someone's
jacket. I'm gonna go straight. La la la. Where are the twins? Are they just dead? That sucks.
Is this food or a pumpkin? Hello? La la la la la la. La. Oh.
I don't like how quiet it is.
Nate or hate. Well, it looks like one of the boys drew a beautiful priest
with some sort of entity in the sun. That's really beautiful. Truly beautiful.
I'm gonna, that pot looks suspicious, you know, you never, you never can trust plants
or television. Don't watch television. It's bad for you.
Oh, that's what makes in the mirror. Despite, oh.
Hello? Despite everything, it's still you.
Um, what the sigma? Can you, can you back up off me a little bit then? Excuse me.
No. What? What? No. Okay. They don't do nothing for you. That's fine.
Boomie. Stop.
Undertail reference. It's death. Follows me. It's death.
Remember the lady in the mirror. Okay. Uh, let's go to the basement first,
because they said basement. So I'm gonna focus on the basement. There's blood.
Love to see it. Uh, I'm gonna, you're a mannequin. You must be demonic. No? Okay. That's fine.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Why is there a random piece of fence down here?
That doesn't, oh, is it like a cradle? Dear Amy, thanks for writing. It really brightened
my day hearing from you. In your letter, you ask what's the weirdest thing I've seen on,
I read that so wrong. Welcome to my crib. I've seen,
that was gonna say seen in missionary, not as a missionary.
The area, I was like, probably not a lot besides the person in front of you. The area
where you're working in has a lot of folks who practice kimbamba, kimbamba. It's might,
might we call it pagan religion? It's kind of a mix of Catholic and African religions, AO.
One of the saints they worship is San La Muerte or Saint Death. That's
Santa La Muerte, Spanish. Yesterday we talked to a boy about 15 when we asked him if he ever
prayed. He said, no, but I have prayed to San La Muerte. He told us about a time he stayed over
his cousin's house and according to him, they prayed to some figures of San La Muerte and the
figures made things in the house move around. He got real quiet and scared looking after that.
We told him he could pray to God and that God wouldn't make him feel scared like that.
We invited him to church, but he hasn't come yet. I need to wrap this letter up and get back to work.
See you later in four months, Layton.
These letters based on our experience development have crazy. What happened if I prayed to Shibi?
You just get crazy sex dreams.
One time, I forget what happened actually because I was super young, but I like swore. I saw like
a malicious entity in my childhood bedroom and I remember I prayed really hard to God because
this is when I was in the church still. I prayed real hard and then I felt better.
No, I think they seem very caught up in something. I'm going to go look at this washing machine.
Jumping up and down, jumping up and down. This is a cobweb. I'm going to exercise it.
Maybe a night terror? Probably. I've already told you guys I've had crazy sleep paralysis,
but now that I'm a little bit more educated on spiritual things,
I'm not really scared of spirits malicious or otherwise because I know how to deal with them.
And anyways, they're usually just irritated that you're there and you can just be like,
I'm just chilling, bro, and they're like, fine, whatever. Hello? Hello? Or any of you demonic?
I'm going to kiss you. Kiss. Kiss you. All right. Well, I'm assuming when I leave this room,
something's going to come attack me. Oh, cool. Nice.
Chibi's house is haunted. No, no, no, no. Well, my house, like my family home was built in,
like, I think the 1950s. And then a family friend, like my parents rented the house from
and their grandfather died. And I think he's like, he went back to the house and like chills,
but like he's cool with me because he knew me since I was little. So we're cool like that.
So he never bothered us or anything. Sorry, left my ritual circle there. I'll be honest with you,
some of the stuff in this won't scare me because like I am could be like, I do have a very open
mind and like, and I know a lot about paganism and stuff. And I love horror movies like this.
So they're mannequins, not demons. It should have been me, not them.
Yeah, you know, I just sexually sleep terrors. That's the only thing you can do. It really turns
the spirits up. They're like, why are you sexualizing me? Could not endure witnessing the
proceedings and honestly, the best thing to do if you think there's something there is you ignore it
and then they won't bother you because they usually get a rise out of you.
When they get a rise out of you, they feel more justified, you know, inside Amy's parents could
not endure witnessing that. Sorry, Boomi had to insert something there. What are you doing?
Oh, he's playing with Reina and Reina's not having it. The proceedings of the right for long.
Mrs. Martin was, I hate how quiet it is, though, hysterical and the thing that was inside Amy was
feeding off of the fear. Father Alred asked me to take Martin's upstairs. I was physically worn out,
but managed to get them back up. Why was I physically worn out? All we did was go down the stairs
or the attic. I don't know. Back to the stairs to the kitchen. Amy was screaming,
mother, mother, the whole time. Finally, I got them to sit down with me at the kitchen table.
After a few minutes, we couldn't hear much of anything down in the basement. So I went
down to check on things. I found Father Alred lying on his back unconscious with his arms spread
out wide. Amy was not in the chair. She went to the attic. Didn't she? Hello. I'm going to walk
around this. I'm not going to walk in it. I can't. I don't really, I think those are like pieces of
demonic runes because there are specific demonic names. And I think I forget the book of like,
it was a book. There's a, there's a lot of books that were not included in the Bible that were written.
And there's one that includes all the names of angels and demons. And I feel like this is one
of the symbols that was in that. If you didn't know that, I can't remember. I think it's,
this is the book of Elijah that doesn't, or something with the E. Somebody looked that up.
I forget. Raina's on my desk now. Raina, please. Raina, what are you doing? No, not Solomon.
Song of Solomon, actually. Book of Enoch. Yes, there's the book of Enoch. Yeah. Yeah, I think there
are stuff that some things are, like there is an account of King Solomon, but I think a lot
of it was removed, especially because God was unappreciative of Solomon after a while,
because he took on so many wives and began to take on their pagan customs. So he lost his favor.
Can I scooch around now? Hello? Okay. Raina, I can't have you do this right now. She's like,
oh my God. You can't sit there. Oh my God, you're so heavy.
I'm sorry. You just got like plopped on the floor. I apologize.
It's because she's thickums. She's got something in my eye doing that.
Yeah. Yeah, there was the Christian Bible also took a lot. Yeah, they took out a lot of stuff,
because they just wanted to, you know,
keeping stuff that was relevant and that could be applicable.
The Bible has changed a lot. There's so many different translations of the Bible.
Oh, my dead. Hello.
Oh, hey there, Amy.
How the heck did I?
Oh, here she comes. She's a man. Sorry, I just got a, I got a thing saying, whoa, here she comes.
Oh, I love the art in this. You can see my heart. It did go up a bit.
I guess I was the only one who thought to check in the attic when I got up there. It was freezing
cold. I found Amy standing in the back looking straight at me like when I first met her downstairs.
We spoke briefly, although it was frustrating to talk to her or it.
I experienced a bit of deception from the demon. During a conversation,
she uttered my mother's first name and in other instances spoke perfect Latin.
I called for help from the others, but nobody came. So I raised my crucifix and began the ride again.
Can I take that? Give me the doll.
Bob must be stationed somewhere in the Middle East. Okay, so Bob must be
the husband, the father sent over this weird doll for Amy's birthday. I'll ask
Anish about it next time we have book club. She looks like she could be from over there.
Her name's Anish. She's probably from the Middle East.
Amy didn't seem excited to see the doll. I think she would rather have a phone instead,
or maybe seeing a baby doll makes her feel so conscious about working at the clinic.
I'm working at the clinic. What clinic is this 15 year old girl working at?
It's interesting because a lot of things, entities can attach themselves to items.
Everything's missing ahead. Excuse you.
So I wouldn't be surprised if something in the house either attached itself.
Oh, Robert Duckie. You're low on Robert.
Oh, what am I supposed to do there?
Amy's just like, don't go in the bathroom, motherfucker. Don't go in the bathroom.
I'll book a self-spire so his face, you don't come power, it could fix this.
Oh, it's so well animated. I would love, I don't know if you guys have watched Molly Moon before,
but I would love a collaboration of this guy and Molly Moon, although they did.
I know Molly Moon did work on a game with someone, but it fell through, but Molly Moon is so unsettling.
No, I looked at this.
It's all, yeah, it's rotoscope. Yeah, it's just like, it's so coolly rotoscoped though.
I'm assuming when I walk a certain, oh, I'm gonna run, I'm gonna run.
I'm assuming I have to leave a room fast.
No, okay. I guess I can't linger in rooms. She just won't let me linger in rooms.
I wanted to chat with the rubber ducky. I'm not allowed.
Yeah, I can't, can I not? All right, I'm going downstairs.
She's chasing me. She's a manny to go away, Amy.
Amy, I'm going back to the basement. I'm being chased back to the basement.
This is bad. Let me go back upstairs. Yeah, okay. Oh, stuck on the stairs. I'm stuck on the stairs.
It's fine. It's fine. She's walking slowly.
Okay, she comes from the table. Yeah. Okay, how do I...
I can't open the door. Is that where I'm supposed to go?
Yeah, I'm only willing to walk to the side. Compellent? Jesus Christ, compelent!
Compellent!
Not no.
Yeah, but where's the key? Where the key at?
I'm forgetting something. Okay. I always found the ideas of spirits interesting.
I've never been able to believe in them since recently. I was raised so that like ghosts don't
exist, but that demons do, but then I realized that there's definitely both.
Maybe I need to play Simon Says.
No, is that not the key? The key is not Simon Says or an Etch-a-Sketch.
Or one of those little pushy thingies.
Do I need to maybe do each room?
Congrats on the 10k. Thank y'all. I'm going back to my roots with my habit.
Erm.
I'm just chasing Amy until the door opens. Okay.
I picked one. I picked the real one. Was I supposed to flash it again?
Yeah, I know she's fucking here.
Pick the right. I looked up to the right because I was like that.
Do I have to do it again?
Oh, okay. I see now. I get it now.
Come here. Come here, you.
I don't know what you said, but sure.
Yeah, whatever you say, girly pop.
Oh, here she comes. I feel like I can hear Boomi eating something.
Oh, come back here. Come back here. Get over here.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I got you. I know your type. It's dead.
All right, I'm going to try to go to every room and do this.
Oh my gosh, she almost got me that time because I walked so close to the sigil.
Hello?
Finally.
Jumping up and down, jumping up and down.
Rubber ducky is awful suspicious. Nah.
I know your type. It's down. Down for what? Down to clown?
Uh, someone threw pasta sauce everywhere.
Molly, speak. Speak of the devil.
The church might contact you in a few days to tell you their version of what happened to me.
I want you to hear it from me first. Find you want me to voice act?
Molly. Sorry, I just had like a gurgle in my throat.
Oh, no, I dropped them my spaghetti.
Molly, the church might contact you in a few days to tell you their version of what happened to me.
I want you to hear it from me first. A year ago, I was involved in the exorcism of Amy Martin.
What they say in the papers about what happened isn't true.
She, father, my superior, with when I confronted her, she managed to cut the power to the house and
her own parents with her own. I have to go back to the house. The nightmares. I'm having no real.
She's still there waiting for me. I can still help her if I don't come back.
Know that I love you and I'm sorry.
Finally free for my social obligations. Welcome back, Jackson. Thank you for the super.
My ex-wife still misses me, but the church covered up this route.
Father Nick Cage. I know I realized I was doing a Nick Cage voice.
Oh, aren't you a fun little guy with a little smiley face who put pasta on the
table? I can do that too.
Hey, bitch. Oh.
Yeah, you look really good.
Ah, debatable.
Your face is just a white fucking sheet. I don't understand.
Who are you? You dancing? Die. Am I supposed to move? I don't. What are you doing, bro?
Uh.
What am I supposed to do?
Run, you fool.
Keep flashing her. I was flashing her. Yeah, I don't care. Can I skip this?
Do you think my face is pretty?
I have to finish what I started.
Be scared by this crucifix.
All right. Do I run away from him?
Oh, my God. This is hard.
Oh, you're so close to me.
You feel so close to you right now. It's a force field. What the fuck? There's two of you?
Now I'm being attacked by gray men. Ah. Okay. I need to like line you guys up so you
guys just like kind of walk with each other. I don't know. You guys are staggered.
Oh, I kind of want to make them go on top of each other. Not like in a sexual life.
Can you guys like stop? Like so close to me. Here. Come all the way over here, please.
Thank you. All right. Cool. That's not working. Oh, God.
Hey. Oh, I'm going. I'm pointing the wrong way. It's fine.
Here. Come over here. Just. Yeah. Just do that.
Whoop. Whoop. Whoop. It's a salad. Oh.
Hey, queen. Oh, you don't have a face.
Oh.
Well, I didn't know I had to hold it.
Mordis. Oh, at least I don't have to do that again.
Oh, you're so pretty.
Die. Die. Die. Am I supposed to run out the way? I'm assuming I'm supposed to. No, not the zap.
Okay. Okay.
Here.
It's not doing it.
Where is she? What is happening now?
Oh.
You. Eenie, meanie, miney. You.
Die. Die. Die. Die. What?
Which one? Which one? You. Freak.
Sorry, I was distracted because I could hear Reina growling at boomie.
Bro, if you keep back-seeding, I'm gonna eat your fucking booty hole. Shut the fuck up.
I'm bad at games. You're supposed to be enjoying that.
Whoop. Whoop. Whoop. Whoop. You. You. What? Oh.
Mordis.
Right. Left. Left. Left. Left. Left. Left.
Backseat's harder.
Okay, I'll chat. Haram, if you don't behave yourself, I'm gonna sound you.
Which one? Oh, frick, I couldn't tell.
Yeah, yeah, you're getting sounded. You're getting sounded. You're getting so fucking sounded.
You're getting sounded with something spiky.
You know what? I'm gonna, I'm gonna turn real small. I'm gonna turn real small,
and I'm gonna climb in, and then we know what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna grow up big again, and then I'm gonna kill you and explode you,
just like how they did in fucking, you know.
Whoop. Whoop. Whoop. Whoop. Whoop. Whoop. Oh, I just dodged that one.
Can you die already?
Yee. Yee. Yee. Yee. Yee.
Yeeah. By the power of Christ. Yeeah. Yeeah.
Whoop. Yeeah. Yeeah.
Wait, am I done yet?
Yeeah. Yeeah. Please. Can I be over?
Whoop. Oh, you slippery devil, ain't ya? My headphone is falling out.
Yay. Oh, oh no. Oh, what's happening here?
Morties.
Babe, this is only phase two.
Phase three. No shit, it's phase three.
I'm assuming I just don't walk along a pentagram.
What the hell?
Oh, no, no, not the time.
No. I can't do this. I need a shock.
Oh, I must piss myself. Make it stop. I don't know how to do this.
She caught me.
Because it's a trinity. Oh my god, no way.
Oh, I thought I was doing a souls game boss. Can I just? Can you? Can you? Bitch. Can you?
Fucking die already then.
Okay, you kind of got it. Oh, sorry, I walked into you. I totally didn't mean to bump you.
Animation doing revivals on this boss, but I know, right? I really like the rotoscoping.
Why do you got a hand? Oh, I didn't mean to step there. I'm really sorry. Hold on,
maybe it's a little bit bigger. Oh, that's discord. It's not what I wanted.
I'm not a fan of puppeteers, but I have a nagging fear. Someone else is pulling on the strings.
Something terrible is coming down through the entire town, wreaking anarchy and all it brings.
I can't sit highly. No, I can't move at all. I curse the name the one behind it.
Amy, I'm Helen at the moon and sleeping in the middle of a summer afternoon.
Oh my god, fucking. Can you? I wasn't even near you.
It's actually my favorite living tombstone song. Get away from me. Get away from me, you whore.
Get away. I don't want horse. I'm a holy nun. I'm a holy fucking nun. I'm a holy, oh my god.
Holy guacamole. I'm a nun. Nope. Nope. I'm a nun. You can't fuck with nuns. I'm a nun.
Nope. I'm a nun. Fuck.
Mortice, maybe don't sit. You know what? I don't have any mods anymore. I'm taking things into my own hands.
Bye. You too. You too.
You're gone. Get out of here. You're both gone.
Suck my clit, bro. I'm not that mad. I'm actually not mad. I just want to, you guys are annoying.
Oh my god. Fuck.
No, you guys, if you want to be a mod, you can apply to be a mod in the discord like everybody else.
My mods just don't exist anymore. I buy myself. So, uh, yeah.
I'm gonna get you. I was, I'm far away from her. I don't understand.
Yeah, actually it's too much work. Honestly, my chat's pretty cool. I don't really have to do much
to be honest with you. Uh, and my mods don't have to do much. So, it's funny. No.
I literally just had a vision. It came to me in a dream where I picked up my keyboard and I smashed it against the wall.
I mean, she's kind of fast. You're right. You're right. All right. Focus up. Focus up queens.
Okay. So, she goes to this side and then she does it to that side. Oh, then she goes down
and then, oh, frick. I meant to get out of the way because, and she bounces and crosses and goes to
that corner and then that corner and then that corner. I'm pointing. You guys can't see. Oh, it's
really dark. I feel you. I don't have any of my lights on for extra spooky. This is the hardest
fight in the game. I hope not. Oh, all right. Queen.
Oh, I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry, my sweet girl. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry.
Oh, you're free. Oh, you're free. Sometimes when I'm like super regi, I'll like, she'll be on my desk
when I'm playing games. Oh, thank you. And I'll just pet her. Oh, you're going to give me a lick.
Oh, thank you for the calming licks. The calming licks. That's what I need. Thank you, queen.
Thank you for licking my hand. Oh, I'm being healed. Being healed by this princess.
Don't chew on my nail. Okay, thank you. Okay. Can you stop? You can stop licking me now.
Oh, you're sweet girl. Sweet girl. Thank you. Go back to sleep.
GG. So save me. You're a whore. Damn.
All righty. Hello. Oh, frick. Nope.
Oh.
It's honestly comical, the way that I don't, my hand is on the mouse and it doesn't need to be.
I don't know when my hand is on the mouse. I'm not using my mouse. Where's my, I don't have my arm
pressed. Let me turn on the light.
Hello. I usually stream in the dark, but I realize that's not good. Oh, I need to charge my,
frick. It's my, okay. We'll see if my phone dies. Oh, no, this isn't a good one. No, just kill me,
just kill me, just kill me, just kill me, just kill me, just kill me. Thank you. I need to get my
charger because my phone is dying.
You're a sweet girl. I need a snack.
Thank you. You want to sneak to charge you? Only going to charge you. Well,
I'm out of uncrustables. I'm out of almonds. I'm hungry. I'm dying. Boomi's on my desk.
You know what this calls for? A waffle. Yeah, right now. This calls for a waffle.
I'm making waffles in the morning. I'm making waffles.
I'm making an egg old waffle with butter and syrup, thick and fluffy butter milk,
just like your mom. But they call it in high school. So I'm saying I knew her well. I knew her very well.
I feel, sorry for acting like a brat. Yeah, brats get caught.
Yeah, I can tan talk. Oh, you guys want to see? You guys want to see? I'm tan. I'm tan. Oh, wait.
I'm tan.
Boomi, get the f**k out the way. F**k out the way. Boom. Say hi. Say hi.
Kiss. Kiss you, Boomi. Kiss you. He's like, please put me down. Yeah, that's your punishment, getting
kissed. How'd you become a Gyaru? I'm black.
I've been told I only have two jokes and it's that I'm black and that I'm white.
And you'd be correct. That is the only humor I have is talking about how brown I am.
What color are you today, Madam? You know, I'm feeling brown. I almost actually was,
I almost was white today because the model, it doesn't, like you can kind of,
you can kind of see, like, I can't, if I made this, it would make, these aren't separated,
layers, and you can see my wrist is white and my arms are right, but they're all connected.
You could see, like, I had to, in order to make this brown, I had to, I don't know,
my boobs are breathing. Don't worry about that. I had to make that part brown, so.
Where are you looking, you harlot? I don't know why I'm, oh, I just realized that my entire outfit
is on for some reason. Don't worry about that. Has that there been there the entire time? Bumi's
lawyer! Zap? Bumi's lawyer?
Photo shoot chance of you in this outfit? Photo shoot chance? Oh, like, you want me to be cute?
I don't know, my ears disappear when that happens, but don't worry about it.
I'm just making funny faces.
Did you guys, like, yeah, I got, did you guys get your photos
so you can study your Bibles later?
It's not yes. Good job. Ignore my white arms.
Okay.
You did what in the name of the Lord?
I can't believe you would do such a thing. Wait, wait, wait.
Don't ask why my face is white.
No, I didn't mean to press that. No, Rick, no! Make it stop.
Wait, go back to the blackest one. What do you mean the blackest one?
Sorry, can you be, like, a newbie in princess for me for just a second?
I accept your apology.
So I will randomly change color when I switch between the toggles. I don't know why it does that.
Like when I change. Wait, what am I pressing? So this is, like, what they first gave me
that I adjusted and I'm like, they say that this is hell bunny where I'm just really red
and look like I'm sunburnt. It's cute. I think I might use this for, like, a succubus outfit.
Oh, shit. That's not what I want to press. Oh, shit. That's not what I want to press.
No, I don't want to turn on that sort of browsing, whatever that is.
Oh, Lord have mercy. I'm about to bust.
Well, is this what you were talking about? That randomly makes me give myself black face?
Is that what you meant?
Yeah, that's what he meant.
Oh, my moderators are here! The charcoal one! Oh, that was loud.
Oh, you already have a photo? Yeah, I know you guys already have a photo.
That shading is kind of normal.
Can you hold on? Can you please toggle it so you look like you're being really inappropriate?
Thank you.
Oh, hold on. My whole outfit is on again. There we go.
Honestly, like the white version of it, but the black one is up.
The black one's all right, I guess.
Brother. Does Bro know?
Does Bro know? Hold on. My waffles need to be toasted again.
So, the reason why I make that my only freaking joke,
one, I like self-deprecating humor, two, people don't know I'm brown.
I look white.
I'm gonna punch you. Punch the mic. Punch the mic. Punch the mic.
Peep, peep, peep, peep. I just look, yeah, I don't.
You can tell that I'm brown, though, because my knuckles aren't pink. You can see, like,
if I was, if I was a white woman, it would be different.
Toasted waffles, just like my Gucci.
Mixed or just light-skinned? Oh, I am mixed and light-skinned.
I'm mixed, mixed, mixed and light-skinned.
Oh, Boomi, come over here. Stop bothering me.
Oh, I still have stew to eat. Oh my God, I got to make stew. Fuck.
What? What do you want, Boomi? Why are you freaking out?
Treat? No treat. Treat? No treat. Treat?
Oh, you just wanted to give me a headbutt. Oh, you just wanted to give me a headbutt?
What are you doing?
Oh, you give me lots of head butts like you want something.
Are you trying to seduce me to give you a treat?
It's not gonna work.
You get fed in 30 minutes.
It's not gonna work, big man. Nice try though.
You got a good effort. Can you give me a physical?
Oh, good physical.
Hope you just got scared by the toaster because you're a little bitch.
You're lightly burnt. It's fine.
Smells good. Delicious.
Mama, mama, mama.
I wanna hold him like I do in Texas, please.
Hold my hand, make me come with a hand.
He loves me. I love it.
I don't even know which child he has.
No, you're not who he meant.
Who's with the woman for the boy.
Uh oh. Uh oh.
Boomi, you can't have a waffle.
Boomi.
I almost dropped my waffle.
Boomi, Boomi.
Boomi, you dropped your pocket.
Boomi, you dropped your pocket. Pick up your pocket, Boomi.
Ha ha, got you. You made you look, Boomi.
Got him.
Yeah, got him.
They take all my trash. Excuse me.
So many boxes.
All the little gifty poos that my harem loves to spoil me with. Thank you.
I think, yeah, the stuff came in in terms of like the shade.
So I'll try to put those up tomorrow.
Boomi, came home and brought us.
I'm not sure if this is true to him. This will not stand. We will see you in court.
Hi, Raina. Hi, Fii.
Yeah, boy. Waffle time.
Again, of his lawyer, Justice for Boomi.
Shut up. Boomi doesn't need justice.
Boomi needs to be arraigned and put in jail.
That's what needs to happen to Boomi.
Denying my client waffles. No!
I'm being rude to this little stand. We'll see you in court.
Money for the Boomi lawyer form. I have to do this three times.
Okay.
Boomi, please leave. He's going to take my waffles. Fii, hold this.
Thank you.
She's so cute. Okay, let me take that off of you.
Boomi, don't chew on my headphones.
Here, I have a brush. I'm brushing you. I'm brushing you.
Ha ha. Ha ha. Get brushed. Get brushed. Ha ha.
You'll flee because you don't like being brushed.
She's just standing there, menacingly.
Okay, fat boy.
I'm putting you over here. Okay.
Okay, I need to shock myself three times.
Uh!
Uh! Wait. I don't think it's on.
Properly. Okay.
Wait, what the heck?
Ah! Okay.
I did it like five times.
Brushing Saturday nights.
Give me the other cat. Fii is not going to eat them.
You want some waffles, Fii?
She's just like, I'm good.
Actually, she likes the smell of the butter.
I don't know.
Priced a bump to shock setting.
I don't know what should be the price be to bump the shock setting.
I didn't do this in advance.
I didn't plan this.
Well, I planned it a week ago, but I didn't really plan out the scum antics.
Guys, I just...
Should I make it that my heart, when my heart rate is 90?
I get shocked? I don't know.
Because I like, again, I have a naturally resting heart rate.
On death? I agree. I think on death will be better.
Okay, when I die, I'll shock myself.
You want some butter, honey and jam?
Chug, chug my lean.
Come, come, my lady, come, come, my lady.
Here, my butterfly. Sugar, baby.
Oh, we need some belly.
Oh, the belly. The belly.
Sorry to mess up your food.
Shocking on good death will be built in good beginning.
Death shock for 15 increase.
Well, I already have it on a high setting, guys.
I can't really go super. I have it maxed out.
And then there's one setting above that.
Are you good for you?
Um, Game of Slaps ships pretty fast, because my order came in, like, three days.
But I'm American, so...
Well, I'm just so funny that nobody laughed.
But I'm American, so, loser.
I already ate the Incredibles, guys.
I was really depressed.
Okay, I eat my feelings when I'm depressed.
Which is often. It's a miracle I'm not a whale.
Thank you, my jeans.
Grocery fun for Shibi. I just went grocery shopping.
Although it's funny, because, like, I put everything away,
and it looked like I didn't get anything, and it was $250.
Hey, yes, whales have feelings, too.
Aw, I love the whales.
Trust me, I really don't care about body tape on other people.
It's funny, because, like, people always, like, freak out about body types.
Like, you just know it's, like, projecting.
And that took me a while to realize that, um, the people just project,
because I realized I was projecting, and then I worked on myself,
and now I don't project.
Now, I love myself and my body, minus my boobs, because they're giant,
but, you know, it is what it is.
You take some, you lose some, you win some.
So, like, I'll be honest with you, like, I used to be big at one point,
and then I was like, fuck it, we're getting,
this is during COVID, like everybody else.
I'm like, fuck it, we're getting our life together, sis.
So, I dropped, like, 50 pounds.
Um, and I used to be, like, a 34D, just, like, a regular D,
and then when I gained the weight, I was, like, a 34F,
and I dropped the weight, and I'm back to, like, where I was,
and my boobs did not shrink.
It was bad.
Yeah, I did, like, a very rigorous, um, like, calorie counting.
Uh, my dad, like, um, I avoided sugar.
I only had gluten, especially because my family is mostly gluten-free
and sugar-free, because my mom, uh, is something similar to celiac,
but she doesn't have celiac, and then my dad is diabetic,
so my family eats pretty healthy in general.
Uh, but yeah, it just, like, and so, like, now I'm, like,
skinny with huge boobs, and it sucks because, like,
I sound so fucking pretentious right now, I'm sorry,
um, because, again, my breasts don't fit my frame,
so I look way bigger than I am.
I will show you right now, I don't care.
Uh, hold on.
So, Jesus Christ.
So, you see here, I look, you know, pretty big,
because my boobs start there, this is my stomach,
and then it's up there.
But if I sit up and I pull back, you can see,
or if I lift up, because my waist is up here,
I'm, uh, I'm a lot skinnier.
Um, so it's just, it looks like a cute, it is a cute baggy
sweatshirt that I got water on.
Nice argument, however it's slapped.
Uh, don't ask me to go.
But yeah, why am I pointing it at myself?
I didn't mean to.
Let's go back to Cat Cam.
Yeah.
Cute baby, she's doing better, I just give her her steroids
because she's going to void it out.
Oh, can I do a big stretch?
Pia, can we do a big stretch for everybody?
Ready?
Big stretch, oh, you guys can even see it.
She's going to stretch a little bit.
Oh, my sweet girl, oh, my sweet girl.
Here, let me give you the, let me give you a little treat.
Pia, where are your treats?
Did I take them out?
Oh, I did.
I need to buy more treats.
I need to go to the cat food store.
I like giving them little minnows, like I give them these.
I'll show you.
My pants are falling down, thanks.
Um, she's chilling.
I like to give them these, they're like little fishies.
You want a fishy?
Let me get you a whole one.
There's not many left in here.
Here you go, damn it.
A fishy?
Oh, you missed.
She's very tired right now, I can tell.
She hasn't been taken, boomie.
Do you mind, bro?
It's, it's hard for her to chew, because like it takes a lot of strength,
so I've been giving her wet food, or softened food.
Good girl, Pia.
Oh, you munchin'.
She almost has to like suck on it like a lollipop,
so it like softens up for her.
Ooh, big rip.
You trying to crunch that, huh, little girl?
Mm, tasty.
She munchin'.
But you can see that she can't really hold her head up.
She's very tired.
It's like a car when it runs out of gas,
so she just doesn't have the strength.
You lickin'?
You want it? Are you done?
Okay, I'll give you like one more piece you can rip off.
You just dropped some, man.
Here, have that little piece.
Have that little piece, eat that.
That's soft enough for you. Here, take it.
Pia, you know how to eat from my hand. Take that.
Come on.
You know, are you done? Okay.
Here, boomie, you can have it.
Boomie, what are you doing?
Take, take it.
No, you don't want it? You don't want this?
Ew, there's like fish guts on my hands.
Here, go eat that. Thank you, sir.
Eat the squeeze of those treats, because, yeah,
I have some chudu, but I'm like the chudu thingy,
so I'm almost out.
If you're new here,
Pia is my little Siamese kitty mix.
She is a lilac point.
She's the sweetest little girl.
She got really nice pinto beans.
She has a rare disease where she is paralyzed from the neck down.
It goes away, though. It's really weird.
If she's on medication for a while, it goes away.
And then she can run and jump and go and do cat stuff,
but she has, I just came back from a trip
and I don't know if me being gone triggered
or stressed her out that she can't move again,
but don't worry, I got her on medication.
I was with her at the vet today all day
because the medication they gave was incorrect yesterday,
so I got rid of that.
I have to wean her off of it, though.
Can't just end it.
But she is a tough girl.
She's very tough. This happened before in March
and she knows her drill, but she's a tough girl.
She's really tough, but she's giving me kisses.
She knows.
I take care of her.
I'm so proud of my O.S.H.I.
Excuse me.
Yeah, why don't you give yourself a little room?
What?
Did I miss something?
My headphones are off.
Whoa!
I'm really happy we're still able to stream
despite everything that's going on.
Hopefully we can return even a fraction of the joy you bring us.
I'm so proud of my O.S.H.I.
and all of her hard work.
Oh, exude Doki!
What the hell, bro?
You literally dropped like 200 last stream, too.
Thank you.
You don't know how much that helps
because I just spent a pretty penny on her at the vet office.
It was expensive.
It was literally...
I always know that I'll be taking care of
because literally the cost of the appointment was $300.
I'm not even joking.
And you just gave that to me.
So I appreciate you so much.
You literally have no idea.
Thank you so much.
And everybody else who's donated this stream,
I appreciate it.
It really helps me pay Fia's bills and my own bills.
You guys know I do this as a full-time job.
So everything counts.
I appreciate every time you guys decide to support me,
whether it be through Patreon or through donations.
I always try to make it worth your while.
So that's why I'm doing this today.
And it's also just fun.
It's just fun.
So I appreciate you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Doki was the vet confirmed.
And it was even sweet because the people at the vet,
they know they've known Finia for a while.
And it was going to be more than that.
It was going to be $600.
And they cut the price of it because they're just like,
because one, they still don't know what's wrong with her.
Although they did, like I almost laughed in their face.
And they're like, yeah, we would need $3,000 for a muscle biopsy.
It goes off to this fancy, like we have to put her anesthesia.
They have to like remove a part of her muscle.
It has to be done when she's like this and she has to go under
and it does a medical procedure.
And then they send it out to a lab in California.
So that's why it's so expensive.
And then I get results in like two weeks.
But I'm like, I don't know what the results are going to tell me.
They're probably going to tell me something I already know,
which is that she has misthenia gravis.
Like we know, I know it's like the doctor is so sure it's neuropathy.
I'm just like, I don't, I might do that in the future.
If it just becomes like a lethal thing.
But thank you guys.
Yeah, it was $3,000.
It's like, bro, what?
It could be.
Yeah, it's had the vet charger so much.
Yeah.
And then like sometimes insurance isn't really worth it too.
Cause it's like, I've had Pat insurance before it costs like,
it like ended up like being even when I paid the cost of the insurance.
And then when I paid the stuff out of pocket.
Oh hi, Elias.
Oh my gosh. Hi.
Elias, Elias.
I can't read bro.
Hi.
Let me chuck a hot girl wrench your way.
Oh my goodness.
Hi.
You want me to, you want me to hold on.
I'm going to embarrass you real quick for a moment.
I was a major creep in Elias's debut.
Yeah, because I really liked that she did multiple voices like myself.
We have a lot of common and we love doing ASMR role plays together.
And when I saw that she had like two little characters.
She had two little characters she did really sick voices for.
I was like, she's my girl right there.
She's my girl. I like her. She's the one.
That's like creepy. That's nice.
She's, yeah, she's a great voice actress.
She's seriously great.
Thank you. Thank you.
No, no, you're sweet.
And she just had a really cool event for her 50 K which was really fun to watch with her and Serena.
Serena and her were hilarious.
I was dying laughing.
They were doing this whole bit where Elias,
Elias, I can't fucking say it.
Elias put Serena in a jar with the suspicious liquid and I'm like,
I thought this was a say so company.
I was wrong.
Oh, my ASMRs are comfy and amazing.
Thank you. Thank you, Elias.
Yeah, no, I love role playing too.
So I noticed that mean her a lot in common.
So it's really cool.
Honestly, the entirety, I put her in a champagne.
Yeah, it was champagne folks.
It was champagne.
But a lot of the girls that V for Mariah are so freaking talented and I'm happy.
They get a lot of the support that they do.
I'm so excited for the 3D debuts coming up for them.
So make sure you guys check out Elias' channel and also check out the other V for Mariah girls because they are absolutely lovely and cool and nice.
I followed them since their inception and I'm bummed that Abby Cadabra graduated but she went on to better things and I'm so proud of her.
She brought something totally new to the VTubing sphere in my opinion and also really cool Brazilian representation so it was nice.
You're so adorable. Thank you so much for your kind of support.
You're so beautiful and amazing.
Wait, I remember Elias says a thing.
She has like a mannerism.
I forget what it is.
You know, I think it's that.
Maybe I'll try to figure out if I can do Imitate.
I try to do impersonation so maybe I can do Elias' voice if I listen to her.
She's my entry. Yeah.
They have really good girls there.
Wait, I just realized I'm missing something on my head.
Hold on.
Hold, sorry. Hold on. Hold on.
Pardon.
Pardon. Hello. Hello.
Oh, there it is.
I didn't realize that.
These are bound to like W, E and R and I've been using those to move.
I don't have my catchphrase is don't get it twisted.
Okay.
You click them. Yeah, I realized that.
I want a cool verbal thing.
I can't say Dio though.
Usually just say bro a lot.
I'm a bro she.
Okay.
So I think we're good.
We got Fia big chilling.
She even she even beeping.
Oh, I'm sorry. Did I make you itchy?
Did I make you itchy?
Oh, let me scratch your ear for you.
I got it. I got it.
Oh, good scratch.
She's like, I must lick my chest.
Boomie.
Boomie did what?
Boomie?
What did boomie do?
I don't have my headphones on anymore.
I'm putting them back on.
So does the three hundred mean thirty zaps?
Do you want me to die?
Do you want me to be paralyzed?
That's the question.
Small amount because I'm just a broke harlot,
but hope it helps.
Oh, sweetie. Oh, anonymous.
Don't feel like pressured because of my situation
that you feel like you need to help. I appreciate it though that you are taking
your harder and money and giving it to me. That is very, very sweet of you. I
appreciate you a lot. Let me quote the Bible for you real quick. Jesus told of
a parable of a widow with two small coins and he was explaining to his
disciples that there's this rich man boasting and telling how much he
gave to, you know, the congregation and then there's this little old lady that
came along and gave two small coins and Jesus always, Jesus asks, so disciples,
which do you think was of more value? The rich man giving away his riches or the
woman who gave her last two small coins and it was that woman. So I appreciate
you. You guys think I don't, that I'm lying about having been raised religious.
Sick parable girl. You do that one like, I do. Do I do that? What are my
verbal tics guys? Hey those are some good stories. Just the church is, well, you know.
What about the Stanley parable? You know, Jesus once told of this story about this
man who lived a very mundane life into the same tasks over and over and over
again and it wasn't until he broke out of his box and discovered that he could
control the world on his terms did he realize who he truly was and that's how,
and that's an example we should all follow. Amen. Shibi Kambam chapter 10
verses 31 through 42. Thank you. Well, you tend to do various voiceovers.
Your choir is no thoughtful. Yeah, this one's one of my favorites. My favorite
parables when Jesus breaks the bread. Yeah, I remember that always, I would
always like badger my mom about that when like the loaves and fishes. I'm like,
but how did he feed all those people? And my mom's like, through the power of
spirit, I'm like, but there's only like two loaves and three fish. How did he
feed a multitude of people? With the Holy Spirit, mother fucker.
Pretty Shibi is you.
Oh, what? I'm just into Findo.
I'm just into Findo. Oh, I just got like a cramp.
Crack my back. All right. Let me shock myself.
Okay, I feel like that was a lot stronger than before.
What the hell? That was so weird. It was never that strong. And I didn't change the
change the setting. I almost pissed myself. Jesus. I'm fine. Don't worry about it.
So Doki, you donated 300. What would you like me to do?
Pissing by yourself, madam.
Whip him. I do have my whip.
We're waiting.
Doki dropped a three hundo, but I don't think I can shock myself 30 times because
that's just not safe. Show hands. Are you Doki? No.
Imagine Doki was Doki bird this entire time. That'd be sick.
I think you die. Probably.
That's not safe for work.
I can wait. The bell dismisses you. I mean, I dismiss you, not the bell.
The bell doesn't dismiss you. I do.
Just a little shock. Just a little shock. You just want a little shock and 30.
You guys can't add on to what they said. You're like, oh, so you need to do a shock
and then 30 jumping jacks. And then I also need you to do 30 push ups.
Oh, thank you. Wait, I thought your name was Mr. Pizza, but it's R&R Pizza.
I bet you tried to make it look like it was Mr. Pizza, which is very smart of you.
Thank you for the 10 super. Oh, Fia giving you a little little wiggle and excitement.
What's up, ma'am? Do you need a piss, girl? Do you need a piss? Do you need a piss, girl?
Do you need a piss? Do you need a piss, girl?
Fia, why do you look so cute? Oh, you're a little trench scratchy. Oh, they were a little trench
scratchy. Okay, let me shock myself. Okay, that one wasn't that bad. Let me do it again.
It was a little tickle.
It's like, it's weird. It's like inconsistent. Like it'll be like one super strong, one super
light for no reason. And then one that one did barely did anything with the hail.
I'm okay.
And then what was the other thing? Can you spit on you? Okay. Yeah, sure.
Low charge? No, it actually went up in charge. It was at 42%. Now it's at 48%.
What? What?
Hi, everybody. Hello.
Let the bodies hit the floor. Okay, so I need to spit. Let me get some.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, Fia, I'm so sorry. I must be so noisy to you. She, like, looks at me like, please.
This is one weird jerk, servants. Okay.
Make me sweat, make me harder, make me lose my breath, make me harder.
I'mma be, I can't see, not more dis. Oh, let me put my headphones back in. Are you ready?
Are you guys ready? Oh, I let me move myself out the way so you guys can see the game.
No, I didn't mean to switch to ASMR.
Well, I'm not doing ASMR, but I'm here now. Please hold.
All right.
Thanks for the hallelujah and spit. Oh, time to shock.
Wait, did that work? I realize I think there's like another part of it that shocks you,
and if that doesn't touch my neck, it doesn't work.
Oh.
Are you guys crying? What the fuck is going on?
It says, yeah, I noticed it's the rivets that shock, not the actual front of the collar.
I see it's not tight enough. He says as he plunges into her back door. Sorry.
Oh, oh, so I was thinking, by the way, random thought.
So I was going to redo the, sorry, I'm looking down because I'm trying to untangle my headphones.
Hi, Pia. What's up? I can hear you trying to purr. When she's like this, she can't purr,
which sucks, so she just breathes funny.
But I was thinking, we have a cat cam. Yeah, you do, bro.
So you guys know we're getting like Halloween outfits. I think I'm going to change my scripts
for October to match my Halloween outfit. You guys don't know what it is. Black and yellow,
black and yellow. Anyone worried about Madam, the collar? She has specific pink flesh shocks
are well within this name. Oh, yeah. See, thank you, Maureen. So you guys don't have to worry,
I'm not dying. Glamis chase away every time I chase. You know, it's really nice to see. I've seen
a lot of pen pals and snowberries and bleeding hearts and snippets and reeflings in my chat.
Sorry, that was my ice maker. If you guys heard that. This person's like, don't tell me. No,
you guys are fine. You know, we don't care, right? You're like, we actually don't care.
But I appreciate and dislike people who are from other companies who have Oshie marks. I thank you
for watching me. I appreciate you. Thank you for giving. I know sometimes
people kind of like stick to one person. So thank you for occasionally watching me too. I think
that's pretty neat of you. I'm happy that I can appeal to you when your Oshie isn't around.
I'm your side Oshie. Oink. That was not a wink. I just blinked with two eyes. Don't worry about it.
Morty's. I'm a tried and chewed degenerate as you should be. Okay, let me not touch this.
Veal our unity. Veal our love. Okay, remember, shock on death. Oh, my cat's food is going off.
My cat's food is going off, ladies and gentlemen. It's fine. We're killing this bitch.
Fuck. I'm shocked myself. Okay, I need to turn that down.
We're turning it down. We're turning it down. I just had a really weird deja vu.
Okay, hold on. Let me feed Veal. I like how I started, died, and I have to feed my cat.
Hi. Oh, you ready for some lunchies? You ready for some lunchies?
Oh, yeah, I know you just ate, but I'm going to try to see if you'll eat again.
It's ordering water.
Let me just... Hi, little girl. She's a very cute girl. I'm using my Tamagotchi box as a stand for her to eat on.
Ma'am, do you need to sit up? She might squeak again. She's not in pain.
She just is vocal when I move her. Okay, guys? Yeah, I know. I know.
Yeah. Here you go.
What do you feel? I want to eat. I want to eat. I want to eat. I want to eat.
My Tamagotchi... No, somebody just got me a Tamagotchi.
I can't floss. I forgot how to do it.
I'm booming in the background. Shitty. Shibby hit the gritty. I don't know how to do the gritty.
Boomi, it's water. You don't need to be a part of it.
She died eight times. It's possible that sometimes a little game.
Siamese cats. I already know for being vocal. Sorry, she's speaking.
Actually, Fia doesn't really talk a lot. That's why I'm just like, I like warm people.
Boomi is the most vocal. Actually, well, Rain was pretty vocal, but Rain is a pure Siamese cat.
Boomi and Fia are part Siamese cat. Boomi is a Lynx point, and so is Fia, which is a Lynx lilac point.
So, her mom must have been like a lilac point Siamese, and then her dad was probably a Tabby cat or something.
Shibby, why the way hit the gritty when you're gritty? Gritty, we hit the gritty. We hit the gritty.
It's special water, Boomi. She's lying to you. He just has to like drink it, and then usually
when she's done, she'll tuck her head to the side, and she'll stick her face to the side.
So, I think she's telling me that she's done with it. Are you done? Are you done, ma'am?
Are you done? Are you done? Hi, Boomi. Okay, let me take that from you. Good Sippys. Good Sippys.
Now, my ankle. And you get more wet food. I'm gonna do that tomorrow, put you this time on my last hand.
And honestly, I should have just saved it all for Fia, but Boomi can be very aggressive. Not aggressive like me, but like you just, I mean like the ball, he'll just go after the food.
He's very food driven, like a freaking dog. Where do I put the food bowl? I just had it.
Boomi, did you take the food bowl? Boomi, I don't trust you.
Boomi, what did you? You stole something again. Didn't you?
Bitch. Yeah, excuse me. Excuse me, handsome boy. I'm trying to find what happened to the bowl,
that I used for Fia's food. Oh yeah, that's right. I put it over here.
Okay, I'm gonna soften the slope.
With a little bit of water and a little bit of chew. So in types of caspias, usually like like food that's been like wedded for her.
Oh, my song's back in my head.
I need to go to the pet stole. I'll take you to the pet shop.
Beep, beep, beep. My pants keep falling down. Beep, beep, beep. Excuse me. Hi.
Boomi. Oh, because you just accidentally made me flop you in the face.
Get a little tighter to eat some. Here, you want this? Here, Boomi.
Boomi is requiring. No, wait, hold on. I want to see if I can
come down here so people can see.
I'm pouring on my cats.
I'll show you where to a two-party, a t-shirt. Boomi, don't chew on it. Just let me,
you don't even deserve treats right now. I don't know why I'm giving this to you. I should have just given it all to Fia.
Leave it. Don't you dare go for it, Boomi. Here, come here.
Come here. Boomi, hey. Bro, get your booty cheeks over here.
That's what I thought.
Wait, we'll just pick you up.
Hey, you can have some of these drops.
Hi, Nino.
My flashlight and the camera and my pants are falling down.
Did anybody see? No. Hey, ma'am, are you going to eat? Come on, you can do it.
Change, ma'am.
Why? She's like, I only wanted the chew-droom.
You and the cat is also a mom here. Leave, Boomi alone. Are you guys to fend?
He's stealing his sick, paralyzed sister's food and you guys are saying stop being mean to Boomi?
Have you seen this beautiful girl and he's taking her food?
He has done nothing wrong.
Watch. Okay, watch him. I'm going to be right back. Can you guys watch my cats? I'll be right back.
Oh, now you want to come over because you're wondering what I'm doing with Reina?
Because you always have to be a part of things, Boomi.
Boomi actually follows me around the house. It's quite adorable.
Even if he's, like, dead of sleep and he hears me get up, he will get up and move.
Okay, Sofia, it looks like you're done with this. I'll give this to you later.
Fine, Boomi. Do you want this? You want this? It seems like you want this.
Although, there's food right there. What's your new goal?
Dinkus.
Look at that lady.
Ah, girl, look at that body. So, by the way, I will be doing this in a stream soon.
I can't remember if I did it for a member stream or a...
I think I did it for a member.
I can't remember. I can't remember if it's a member.
Member. Member?
He wants her food. She might be the leader of the pack.
Wait, what? How high did my heart rate go?
For what? It's because I'm talking and running around.
Apologize to Boomi. I'm gonna ban your ass.
Sounds like you're the villain here, Sheebie. What rules of nature?
Oh, my God. You guys are enabling my son who is steals.
He's a thief. He'll attack her when she's like this, mind you.
He'll attack her. Actually, Thea, I'm gonna flip you so you're more comfortable.
Here you go. Fine. Did you want to be like that?
She's like, I want to lean. Lean with it, Rock with it. Lean with it, Rock with it.
She looks so angry on the camera.
Demonic. Oh, yeah. This was the slime, by the way.
I want to do like a slime fun so I can get more slime.
This was slime that I did for your ears.
Yeah. Raina has been, yeah, she's actually been chilling. She's been walking around.
She's actually been on my couch right next to me because my couch is right next to my desk.
And so she's just chilling there. She also followed me into the bathroom when I was like,
Raina, come with me. We're gonna go talk shit about Boomi.
Goopiest ears known, does she have goopy ears? Yeah, do you have goopy ears?
Yeah, goopy ears. What are you talking about?
Boomi makes sure her ears are clean. Sorry. Okay, someone, okay, let me do 10.
Ah, okay. This is a cloud slime. Here, I'll show you.
Eat the cloud slime. Sorry, I fuck up your ear for you.
She's like, I can't scratch it. Eat the cloud slime.
Your ear okay? Let me scratch your ear for you. Let me wipe my hand off of it. It smells like,
um, straw, it smells like strawberry milk.
Look, it's a fucking beauty tutorial. Is your ear good?
Hi, Boomi. Is this the menace you guys ordered? His paws is coming. I'm scared he's gonna knock
over the camera. I'm covering my face in anticipation. He's sniffing her ears.
Funs for Boomi's lawyer for all the slander. Oh my god, you guys are terrible.
Boomi, can you get off my desk? Boomi, please. Boomi, please, don't sit on my keyboard. Boomi.
Boomi, please. Boomi. You smell like fish. You smell stinky. Can you leave?
Big man. Big man, can you move? Lily's sitting on my keyboard.
Hi, Yemi. It's Jimmy. All right.
Oh my god. My favorite little sister is here.
Am I gonna keep streaming? Uh, yes. Oh my god. What time is it? Oh my god,
don't even three hours? Jesus Christ. I don't know if you guys heard Raina just
hiss at Boomi. Raina knows what's up. Raina knows what's up. She knows. She knows how we do.
Oh yeah, by the way, thank you for the woofer. I said I wanted a stuffy of a woofer and a
Pokemon smasher pass and then literally got a surprise gift from Throne and somebody bought
me a woofer and he's just a little guy. He's just a little guy. Right, Fia? He's just a little guy.
So he's on my desk.
Didn't hear it. Circumstantial evidence. Boomi's still innocent.
Yeah, the woofer's cute. He's on my desk next to the bunny. Oh, let me show you. Hold on.
Somebody also, wait, I can try to find... I don't know what I did with the... Hi, Raina.
Squeak ladder for everyone to use. Oh, Boomi, where the hell did you come from?
I accidentally just bonked him in the head because I left my cabinet open.
Where is it? Where is it? Did you take it, Mr? I feel like you took it.
Um, what was that? What was that? What are you cooing about? Oh, here it is.
Hold on, I got you. So somebody got... So somebody got...
Um, pieces to make a hero member.
So I don't know if you guys can really see, but it's fine. So they got a bunny. He looks a little
scary, but it's fine. He's a little bunny. And Amy Raid. Hi. Hi, Momosa. And so I got him a little...
Somebody got him a little bow tie. I'm dressing up hair. I'm right now. Hi.
And so now he has a bow tie. I also put it on Boomi at one point.
And they also... His... Oh, his ears are stuck. This is actually hard to put on him.
The hero backpack indeed. So, uh, except you can't use the, like, straps because of the bow tie.
Um, so yeah, he has a little bow tie. It's quite cute. Very nice. Very dapper.
Um, and then they also got him a fedora.
So, and he's just been chilling on my couch. So, um, yeah.
So he sits next to me on the couch and I watch TV.
I can just question between my thighs. Get down there here. Okay. Um,
not the mullady. Oh, but Phi is doing okay. I just gave her... She's like, what the fuck?
She's like a, like, uh, what's it called? Um, office. Look at the camera moment there.
Uh, she is doing okay. I just gave her her food and her water. Um, she's still, uh,
it's gonna take her a while to go back to normal. It'll probably take her like two weeks,
maybe three weeks. So we'll see.
What if Phi was evil and fucked up? Phi is the sweetest cat.
You guys don't even know. Phi is literally the sweetest cat.
She loves to kiss you. She loves to make air biscuits. She loves to give you,
like, she loves her belly pet. She's the sweet... I've had many cats and I've grown up with around
many cats from my family, friends. She is one of the sweetest cats I've ever met in my life.
And that's why she doesn't deserve any of this. Not that any animal deserves it, but you know,
you know what I mean. You gave him a bombastic side eye.
So what's wrong with my fellow heart? Because Boomi keeps taking Phi's food
and I've been yelling and scolding Boomi and people are like, Duff and Boomi, Boomi.
Justice for Boomi. Boomi's a menace. She keeps hearing me say his name and he's like walking
over like, what? Sorry, Phi has pills on my desk. So you adopt her? Yeah, I rescued
Phiia from... You're really using the bathroom right now, bro. Boomi's really just pissing behind me.
I rescued Boomi and Phiia within a month of each other. They're not from the same litter,
actually. Boomi's a month older than Phiia, but they're the same type of cat. So both Siamese
mixes. And Reina, my mom got her from a breeder. And Reina is 14 years old. She's an old lady.
She's the purebred Siamese and she's a blue point. But yeah, is your Boomi creature named after
Earthbender? Yes. Boomi King of Umashu. You have Phiia, the deathbed companion. Yes, I know her
name is ironic given that she is paralyzed, the majority. She's fine though. She's good. And then
Reina is just Reina. Boomi probably has broken the Geneva... Oh, Boomi has broken the Geneva
convention. Honestly, like I'm the type of person who makes jokes just so I don't ball my eyes out.
So I like sometimes I'll just sing to her and I'll just be like, when your legs don't work like
they used to before. She doesn't know. You guys know I try my hardest with her too. I'll just
lift that up a bit. Yeah, but I'll laugh and cry. Am I right? You got the wooper in the background.
And so yeah, Phiia is a good girl. Phiia deserves a world, but she's going to get better. She has
a weird disease where like her body decides just not to work anymore. It's like the doctor says
she like runs out of gas a lot faster than humans. But it just seemed like it was worse.
Worse is not a word. More worse this time. So I'm wondering why that is. So I hope that it's
something that doesn't take longer for her to heal and that if this happens again, I don't want it
to be worse again. We have to wait and see because she was a rescue. I don't know anything about her
genetic history. So it's really weird. I don't know if you guys just started being... Can you guys stop
fighting? I'm gonna burp back to you in anger. Stop. Bumi, leave her alone.
Bumi, she's literally growling at you. She does not want to spend time with you right now.
Oh my god.
Burp of authority.
Fia doing the stinky leg? Oh my god.
Hi, Rina. What's up? Where have you been? Where you been, Loka?
Have you been sleeping under the bed? They like to sleep under the bed.
Rina, why do you have to come from this side to hop up on my lap? Because I know that's where
you're going right now. Hold on, let me put my blanket down so you don't scratch up my legs
because I'm wearing shorts. Okay, I'm ready for you big mama. Hey mama. Are you gonna come jump
up here or are you just gonna walk around me? Hi, I'm Carl. Okay, she's just gonna stare at me,
so I'm gonna continue playing. I appreciate the random Spanish anytime. Anytime.
Fia needs a bodyguard. Yeah, her bodyguard is Rina. When Rina was really sick,
like a couple of weeks ago, Fia was by her side and I was like, Fia, you better not be
her death bed companion or I'll be very pissed off. But you know how it is. Oh,
now as I put my headphones on, you want to go on my lap, Rina? Nice. We have been joined.
By Rina. Oh my god. Stay. Stay. Stay. Can you please?
The man, the woman, the myth, the legend, Rina. Wait, hold on.
The man, the myth, the legend, Rina. And she's climbing onto my head, ma'am. I can't.
I can't hold you like this. Rina. Rina, I can't hold you like this. You're on my headphone wire.
So you guys see what I have to deal with?
I have to deal with three unruly children and one of them is out paralyzed. She just like
pushed off. Scratch my leg. I'm sorry, Rina, but she was like, she sits on my headphone wire.
Like, oh my god. Back to Fia. Hurting cats, literally.
Rina, please. Rina, why? Rina, why have you betrayed? No, she'll be back in like five minutes.
She's behind me right now. She's just staring down, Bumi.
Wait, there should be a way that I can actually like sample something.
Do. Do.
Is it gonna work?
I don't know how it works. I don't know how to sample something and play it.
She told me her name was Benji when she crossed the scene.
Gonna be relentless while we're moving her neck.
They're going to grow up into great cats. Oh yeah.
I don't remember the lyrics, to be honest.
Whoa. What the hell?
Jason Derulo. Jason Derulo.
T-Pain. Get money.
If you want to be no other, you gotta get with my friends.
Make them last forever. That's up to the end.
She said I am a one, but the kid is not my son.
So tell me what you want. What do you really, really want?
I want to, I want to, I want to, I want to.
If you want to be my lover, you gotta get with my friends.
She's just a girl who says that I am the one, but the kid is not my son.
And I suspected the game stream trying to do you. I'm sorry.
Oh wait, hold on, hold on, I got you, I got you.
Because I'm a nun, so I naturally have to sing this.
The hills are alive with the sound of music.
How do y'all get the emotes? You freaking pay for them, bro. What do you think?
They upgraded to the emotes here. Are you new here or something?
What's up, new friend? Come on, sign up for my subscription and be my, um,
hair member in my heartlet. I'll take good care of you. I'll give you a kiss.
So subscribe to, well, member today. Ready? Are you, if you do it, I'll kiss you.
You sound like a 2011 anime VI? VI? I'm a 2011 American...
No wonder I feel like so tired. Fuck you.
You won't regret it. Thank you, boy, for the one gifted. Imagine it went to that person.
I'm trying to like, I'm trying to hold a note but then think of a song to lean into,
but then I can't think of a song.
What was I listening to today? I was listening to, I was listening to Baby No Money,
the song It Boy. I was like, this actually slaps. Holy crap. And then right after that,
I listened to her by Megan Thee Stallion. I'm like, this used to be a remix.
I need to mash up the song. Whoa. Whoa. Why did the, why did the pitch go up? You get a kiss.
Thank you, next. Thank you, next. I'm so fucking grateful for my harem.
How do you feel about the Gen Z Eminem? I always, I thought that was a good line in the thing.
I actually don't really listen to Baby No Money, but it was, that song popped up on my
like recommended, so I was like, clicky.
Oh, thank you for the gifted Benji. Benji Bailey. Bailey. That's your kiss right there.
That's for you. Only you and you only, only you. It's funny because in my, oh, you want a kiss?
You want a kiss? Hold on, let me get, I'm going to give you a kiss. Are you ready for the kiss?
Are you ready for the kiss? Are you ready for the kiss?
There you go. I said in British, you know, you guys know I go British all the time, NFT perp.
I used to, in my PL, I used to dedicate every time I burped to somebody and there was a redeem
because I used to have Twitch. I would, they would redeem to be get the burp dedication.
And when I happened to burp, I'd be like, insert name here. That was for you. Stay beautiful.
I guess it was kind of wet. I like your mom's pussy.
You know what else is wet? My mom. Sorry.
Jb going British to do a best Andrew Tate impression. What? Andrew Tate's not British.
Water? Water? I imagine use that voice to the key and funny voice for those reduce specifically.
Um, no, I've used, I've used my PL voice a lot actually. Outing your mom like that.
Peeler.
Anyways, games, right? I've just been, I'm actually just stalling for time. Nobody called me out.
Oh, wait. Hold on. I fucked this up already. Hold on. I fucked this up already.
Damn it. Fuck. Okay. Hold on. Shocking time.
None. Shibby peek. Aw, thanks, namesword.
That wasn't that bad. Hold on. I don't think it's touching properly.
Yeah. Okay. That was it. Morty's. Morty's. Guys, I will beat this.
That's when I start throwing shit at the wall.
This is not working. Oh God.
Ha, bitch. Oh, I was in your circle of death. I didn't mean to get so close to you. I got a shock again.
I feel so close to you right now. It's a force field.
Morty's.
Welcome, Mr. Pizza.
Mr. Pizza, let me ask you. Do you know the muffin man who lives under Rulee Lane?
No, I walked into her. I can't believe I've done that. I can't believe it.
Rainer, why are you hissing at Boomi? Boomi, what are you doing?
Seriously? What are you doing, mate? Come here.
Boomi, you made such a mess. You kicked shit out of the litter box. Why would you do that?
Boomi, leave her alone.
He full on just jumped on Rainer. I've never seen him do that before.
Dude, you're getting real ballsy with her. Respect your elder. I think he's realizing
now that he's bigger than her and he's not a kitten anymore, so he doesn't have to take her
shit. Boomi, come here. Mr. Yeah, get over here. Don't try to seduce me.
What are you doing? Stop trying to attack or not attack. You're just trying to play with her,
but she doesn't want to play with you. Can you not? Can you stop assaulting old women?
Sir? Sir, do you have a moment to talk about how you assault old women?
Hmm?
Rainer's looking at me like, why did you buy him?
Did I shock myself already? I don't remember.
Phoebe's heart rate was higher than the intermittent because I don't know. I just
lock in during a stream. Falsely convicted.
I gave myself a little shock. It didn't make me yelp, though.
Okay, we're here. We're there. We're everywhere. We're in. We're so inmates.
Oh, I try to run out of the way in time.
Oh, let me shock myself. That's kind of stung a little, but in a good way.
Okay, then she's going to bounce up and then go down and I'll be like boom, boom,
ba. I got that boom, boom, pow, and then I'm going to run away.
Then she's going to go in the corner and then I'm going to get her in the corner
and I'm going to go down and I'm going to be in her fucking way. All right.
Danger, danger. High voltage. When we touch, when we kiss, danger, danger.
High voltage. When we touch, when we kiss, when we touch, lover.
No, no. Ah.
Fire on the disco. Fire in the Taco Bell. Sorry, I've shocked myself.
Guys, I think it was a bad idea to change it to death. That's not fair.
I don't think that's fair at all, but that's just my opinion.
And Boomi is chasing her again.
Oh, fuck, I went the wrong way.
How could this happen to me? I made my mistakes. Like I get the rules now.
I just can't fulfill them. No.
How's that? This is, this is bad mood.
Oh, I keep getting in the wrong way. What's wrong with me? Oh, I got to shock myself.
All right. Well, I was standing there while I was shocking myself. So I'll shock myself again.
Hello? Are you there? God, it's me, Margaret.
What's happening? Boomi, I hear you making noises behind me. Just chill out in the bed.
I don't want to, I put the bed there for you. Just, just chill. Just chill, just chill, bro.
Just go to sleep. Just go to sleep. Just go to sleep.
I'm not fucking close enough.
I'm killing myself in Minecraft.
I'm killing myself twice.
It's shocking, shocking.
Guys, I love this game.
Why is this harder than Dark Souls? I mean, harder than Elden Ring.
Although I know the pattern and everything. I'm just silly goose.
No.
You know what it is? You have to run to each side, like the star. Like you also make the star yourself.
It's funny.
No, oh my god.
I'm going to like give myself, paralyze myself
in Minecraft. I just scared Boomi with my, with my yell.
He just Tokyo drifted around the corner.
Oh, how could this happen to me?
Morgan, you fucked me up.
I just shocked myself twice.
Those are accurate. Sorry, I just sneezed. Those are accurate.
Is there, is there just going to be a role play of people going back and forth in the text
of speech about like your honor, my client, Boomi is innocent and then someone else can
be the defense and then someone could be the prosecutor and be like, uh, judge, uh, your
honor, you will see that Boomi has committed all these felonies and he still is evading the law.
Mori can is. Thank you, Morgan.
That'd be funny. Wait, where'd my game go? The hell?
Oh, right. Now you're back in your spot.
No, no, I'm not asking you to leave. That's fine. You can stay there.
Because sometimes when I talk to Reina, she'll just like, I may be like, oh,
you want me to come over and I'm like, no, no, no, you're fine.
I want to scream so bad, but I have neighbors. That was a week. Hold on, let me fix this.
Hi, sheebie. Sorry the priest guy has the agility of a rock,
missing all the best for your baby. Sheebie love. Oh, thank you, boy. Thank you so much.
Ow.
Okay, I've done what I must.
If I have to look at this girl, how an arm come out of her head,
more times I'm going to make freaking lose it.
I'm not close enough.
What was I inside her circle?
I don't even know. Okay. Anytime you hear me go, that's when I shot myself.
John and his broken leg are not helping this run. I know. Look at this little fucking gate. It's so funny.
Die. Are you serious? You're not dead yet?
Where are you going? Where are you going? Where are you going?
Wait, I need a shock.
That didn't work. Just kill me. No, don't kill me. Oh, just kill me.
Why is it firing Japanese at you? Good question.
You want to walk revelation so hard? You think I would peg it? Oh, no, I would peg a priest.
You guys want to dress up as my priest and I'm a nun and I peg you? Oh, that sounds good.
That sounds like good stuff.
Oh, my God. I almost fucking got caught. Die. Die. Fuck.
I'm like, I'm so silly. He sticks out his head. He's like, ah.
Ow. That one hurt. The fuck? I was like stinging. More kids. I have to fart.
Sorry, I had to fart.
I'm coming for you, bitch.
I got you right where I want you. Frick, I was in your circle.
I'll shock myself after I'm walking in, guys.
Yeah.
Hold on. Let me get over there.
Okay. Okay. Can you be my altar toy?
I like that, yes. I'm walking in. No talking. I'm in here. I'm good.
I'm so sorry for you.
I'm so sorry.
Scared the call. Oh, man. I'm so sorry.
Oh.
I think your name is DJ Mortis. Okay.
I'm gonna let Fia eat. I'm gonna be good and let Fia eat.
I'm about to make a DJ remix with all these people. Oh, what the fuck am I doing?
They accidentally closed the game. Okay, no, I didn't.
Locking in. We are locked. We're locking. We're ready for lift off.
Die. I was in her circle. It doesn't matter. It's fine.
It's fine. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it.
You think I would have memorized where she goes already? No, I'm not that fucking smart. You serious?
I remember there's a timing. That's fine.
Frick. Boomi is wanted in six states for money laundering and tax evasion.
Locking in, part two.
Boomi. Boomi, you're in the way. Boomi, please. Boomi, I can't see past you.
I blame Boomi.
Are you going to go snuggle with her? Because if you want to lay in the bed with her,
that's fine, Boomi. Like, you know, you can snuggle with your sister.
He just sat on my hand. He is sitting on my hand.
He is pulling on the move, my gamer subs. He is sitting on my hand. You see that?
He is sitting on my hand.
Boomi. Boomi. Boomi. I'm going to keep pinching your little booty cheeks.
Boomi. Can you move? Can you move?
Why are you wagging your tail? You're the one sitting on my hand.
Can you just want a head pat? I'll give you a head pat.
If I give you love, will you be okay?
Oh, my good boy. Oh, good boy. Wait, what's up with your shoulders? What's that?
Oh, you just felt your fur was messed up.
Oh, are you going to come snuggle with me, Boomi?
Boomi, come snuggle with me. Let me hold you. Oh, my big man. Oh, yeah. I'm holding him.
Oh, big man. Give you the kisses as I hold you. Oh, my little baby boy.
My little baby boy. My little baby. The babyest boy I've ever baby boyd before. He's the baby.
Oh, my client, Boomi, was one of the little ones. Yeah, now he's totally settled in my arms.
Ah, I'm getting like the worst fucking crabs.
The baby boy. But I also want to play the game and he's in my arms. Oh, what's the matter? Did you
see something? Whoa, what's the matter, Boomi? He started wagging his tail like really irritated.
Did you see something? What's the matter? I'm just holding you. I'll put you down.
I need to piss off because Fee is in the bed. I don't understand.
Are you jealous? Are you jealous that she's in the bed? Oh, he did a mighty big plop on the
floor, so he's fine. I think he is sleepy. I think he also is maybe harassing me to go to bed,
although it's only 10, so he's Amy.
All the boys and all the girls are pebbing to F if you seek Amy. Great song, Britney.
It's Britney, bitch.
It's Will I Am in Britney, bitch.
No, I wasn't. I wasn't in your circle. I wasn't in your circle. Is there something I'm supposed
to do after she goes to every side? I wasn't in it that time. That doesn't make any sense.
Oh, I got stuck. I'm surprised she didn't hit me.
What?
I clipped my toe, clearly. Yeah, I know her movement is a pentagram the same time,
but sometimes I don't get close to her and she's still...
Like, what is that? I didn't even press start.
Let me just...
Wow, I suck at this game. Anyways, am I stuck? What was that? I was perpetually, you know,
healing her the power of Christ.
I'm backing up. I'm backing up while I do this.
I was gonna... Oh, what are you doing? What are you doing?
Why are you...
What the fuck is happening?
Fucking trust you. What the... This bitch went out the window. Oh my god. Oh my god. First
I had a celebratory shock. Celebratory shock. Celebratory shock. Oh, nice.
Wait, I feel like someone doughnosed. Oh, I think you missed your pizza for that.
Oh my god. If you're a big chilling, she's hanging out with a whooper.
Okay, okay, okay, what time is it? It's 10.
What day is it? What's today?
Today is Tuesday. It's Tuesday, innit? I got you good. I got you fucking good,
mate. You're a fucking sly, then. Absolutely fucking mental users. It's Tuesday.
Okay, yeah, tomorrow I have a member stream. If you're a member, I'm gonna bake for you guys.
I don't know what I'm gonna... I wanted to do the easy bake-off-in thing,
but that's not gonna come in time. Maybe there's one nearby that I can...
But actually, I don't have any fucking money. So I'll probably just actually bake you a cake.
Just like a little box cake and I'll decorate it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. I'm almost done with this chapter. Thank you, my little back cedar.
He's like, play the fucking game. Shut up. They're here for me, a cute girl. Relax.
Yippee. Yippee. Yoppa. Yodda. Oh, do I need to go downstairs? I feel like I need to go downstairs.
It's quite quiet. Hi. Hi, Saber. I'm really here for boomy. Sorry. Kill her.
I don't think so. That says re-lilk. So maybe I need to go get some milk.
I'm shooting myself. How do I shoot myself? Do I go in the mirror and I shoot myself?
Let me go shoot myself. Yeah. Let me just...
Uh...
Do I need to find more bullets? I don't have any...
Hey, y'all got any bullets around here?
Go back to the room, like, gun response?
All right, time to go kill myself again.
Despite everything, it's still me killing myself. All right.
If it's a gun with one bullet, is it just magically respond? I don't know.
I'm... Shut up.
I'm getting a horror looker. Hold on.
I hate being a woman.
Can you guys, like, hold me? See my heart rate expect a little...
I'm in a lot of pain.
Are you okay? No, I'm a woman. I'm having period cramps. They hurt like a bitch.
Oh, this was really sharp.
Oh.
Uh...
Oh, I'm assuming I'm supposed to move. Die.
Die, bitch. Why do you look like what's his face from the TLC? Oh, what's his name?
Misma? I don't know. Okay, I think there's a man.
Midra? Midriff? Crop top?
Crop top? Drop top? Can you, like...
Oh, I don't know. No.
Oh, why do you look like a giant sunflower coming for me?
Come for me, sunflower. Come for me. Come for me, sunflower.
Yeah, you want this. You want this. You want this little sunflower ass. Oh, god, you're faster.
Uh... That's fine.
There's a monster in the closet. Oh, a note.
Find and defeat the secret boss of chapter... What? There's a secret boss?
October 23rd, 1986.
Dear Dr. M-
It has been 30 days since the beginning of my treatment here at Yale Psychiatric Institute.
Dr. Spinnell has been so patient with me, has helped me understand my afflictions,
has helped me find a way to move forward and accept the truth. With Dr. Spinnell's help,
I have come to accept what really happened in September at the Morton family residence.
I accept that what happened was not the result of any supernatural phenomenon,
but rather the desperate actions of a young girl driven by violence by her dogmatic parents
in old church rituals that are thought to drive out evil.
Oh, so it was all in my head.
It's in your head. In your head. Zahambe. Zahambe. Zahambe.
Oh, oh. Anyways, I'm happy to report that since accepting the truth. Wait, why am I British?
I'm supposed to be in a cage. My nightmares have ceased to know. I enjoy peace of mind that
I've not felt since the incident. Given my progress since first coming here,
I respectfully request, I respectfully request, I respect fully request. I respectfully request
my release from Yale Psychiatric Institute contingent upon follow-up appointments with Dr.
Spinnell in the future. Sincerely, Nick Cage. Singing emo. I need to get one with like a microphone.
Oh, it looks like he's dancing. No, we knew it.
Nicky cotton cake. Oh, so I still need to kill her.
Okay. Oh, I didn't mean to press that. I accidentally pressed space. Hold on.
Wait, what? Sunflower man just like in the thing. I have choices. Okay, so she's either in the
basement or in the attic. What's the difference though? Because they say she's in the basement,
then we say she's in the attic. She already left. Oh,
you're right. She didn't leave. She jumped out the window. Maybe she went back in. I don't know.
I don't feel like going back to the basement.
What if I just go home with my really large cigarette?
Like I'm holding a big ass cigarette.
Going, going, going. Just to smoke my giant ass cigarette. Giant ass cigarette.
Giant ass cigarette. She's in the well, but I can't use it. I can't shoot the well.
I'm going back to my Toyota Corolla with the sick spoiler. Man, this is really big forest.
But I'll just, okay, cool. Die.
Oh.
Erm, what the shibbity?
Because I have made the Lord my refuge. Because I have set my love upon him.
Therefore will he deliver me. I shall call upon him and he will answer me.
He will be with me in truck.
Truck, my beloved. Hello. You've been hit by, you've been struck by a fucking 18-wheeler.
Wait, so the white thing was her? She was the, she was the white boy all along?
Oh. There's multiple endings.
What the fuck? Is this the true ending?
No, that was the boy. She was not the white boy. Interesting. Because it said kill her.
I'd say this is the sequel. And then you don't know what happened to her brothers.
I'm assuming you go upwards.
IDK. At least you're honest, bro.
It's the best ending of chapter one, yes. Okay. I'm assuming you, can't you, I'm assuming you
can go and find her and kill her.
And because it says kill her. So I'm assuming maybe I go up towards the forest and I can go kill her.
Have you gotten the other ending? Bro, I, it's been four hours and I only just finished the game.
Because I am a yapper. I get distracted. I'm tempted to go make myself a PB and J right now.
Because we did what did I eat? I just ate. I had a waffle. I had two waffles actually.
I just finished the first chapter.
One hour half. Yeah, that's how I do. That's how I do. We do one and a half hours of gaming.
Oh fuck. Am I just like closed out everything?
Don't you feel blessed? Oh, Fia, why are you so wiggly? Are you okay?
Are you trying to get comfy? Hold on, let me help you.
There you go.
I know. I'm just taking forever with the shock collar. Which reminds me, I have to shock myself
like five times.
Okay.
The lore. The lore is good.
I know. I mostly look around the internet and truly kind heart is the real thing.
Are you saying I'm kind hearted?
So, thank you. Got to sleep. Good night. Oh, thank you.
Finally, you beat it. Here you go. Do I have to shock myself five times?
One, two, three, four, five.
Thank you. Thank you.
Oh, it's itchy.
Sorry. I'm checking because it didn't show up on my stream elements.
Stream elements is just being weird right now.
Oh, thank you so much. It could binge Faith Ward. What?
She read up on the lore, hid you in bible.
So, I watched a YouTuber play this entire game, but I don't remember any of it.
That was like years ago. Ow, my nose.
Oh, yeah. What's it? It's just good. Well, you guys.
Nunchibi, what? Was like the prayer? Was like the thank you? Like a prayer? Nunchibi?
I want to be a nun so bad.
But I can't.
One degree is the best video. This is very low. Oh, okay.
Because I totally would like watch like a five hour lore video because you guys know I love lore of
shit. Sister Shibidi, I have sinned multiple times.
Joke. Why did you have to do a tone indicator? Oh, they're so funny to me.
It's a five hour lore video. Wait, is it? Oh, perfect. I'll watch that.
Oh, love it. Oh, I love it. Let me take this shot color off.
Whoa, we should have a Shibidi react to Wendigo video.
How I slowly realized she can't trust her government at any level and also horror game rate.
I don't trust my government at any level, but I don't care at this point because they
have all the information on me. There's nothing I can do. I am just a sheep among the people.
I am a sheeple. I am nothing but fodder to the larger system that is capitalism. Anyways.
So how long until the confession stream?
Oh, that's very interesting. He's a youth pastor. Interesting.
I need to blow my nose, but the tissue box is so far away.
But blow my nose, Fia. Fia's like, what? I don't know, my sweet girl. I don't know, my sweet
girl. Yeah, my sweet girl. I'm going to give you your medicine when we wake up. Oh, you're giving
me smiles. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. What do I do? What do I do? What do I do?
I'm supposed to stream by living on outfit. Fia cam. Yeah, we got Fia under cam. We got the
Wooper. Fia doesn't like that idea. I've never watched that person. I've never heard of them,
but I love lore videos. I'm just sad that like I can't watch game theory because it's not MatPat
anymore. It's not the same. It's not this British dude that does his voice and I'm like,
he's cool, I guess, but it's not the same. So I'll watch. Maybe I have heard of Wendigoon. I don't
know. What part of the Bible are we studying today?
Sorry, it's long. You're going to study this part and hold on. I wish I had a ignore that my freaking
thing. Am I fixed that right now, actually? I'll fix it later. Looks like kind of cool,
actually. Looks like I'm glowing, floating. You're going to study that and then you can
picture. This is your little head and I'm crushing it. I'm crushing it.
It's getting crushed. Crushing. No feet. It's over. I am annealing. I'm literally annealing.
I am prostrated and supplication to the Lord.
No, not prostated. Everybody relax.
Wait, I want to see if I already got limited. YouTube hates me, Lily.
Oh, it leases streaming in literally 15 minutes. I'm going to gap for 15 minutes and I'll raid her.
Oh, wait. Yeah, I might as well because Mercy is not going to be on till 11 if she's, I don't
know if she's streaming today. I haven't looked at any of the schedules. Erm, what the shivity?
What am I doing? I totally already forgot. Oh, yeah, that's right.
When we go big time.
All right, still says it's on. That's going to change.
Let me see. Yeah, I take Fia to bed. What the shabaththy?
Oh, that's Shabaththy. Oh, wait, I didn't mean to do that. Hold on. Actually, let me just scoop.
Why isn't my mouth tracking working when I turn to the side?
There we go. Oh, look, it's me. Why is my body darker? That doesn't make any sense. It's fine.
Looks like I'm flying with my ears. Mortis. Mortis. Can someone just like edit, like, oh, shit.
33 cents. Thank you for today's sermon. Sister, she be blessings be upon you.
Blessings. Blessings be upon you too, my child. I'm not currently
robed, but it's fine. Don't worry about it. I am going to get dressed expeditiously.
Hold on. Please hold. Oh, I lost my mole. It's fine. What is this? Hello? Get rid of that. Where's
my head? All right. I like this. Hey.
This is a little bit bigger. There we go. What up? What up, bro? My head's so big. Don't
worry about it. I think my head's actually too big. Let me just. No, let me on. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Let me. Let me do this. No. No. I am a bobblehead. I have, I have non consenting proportions,
as they say in the internet.
Yeah. Oh, fuck. I didn't take my body. Frick. I didn't take my body with me.
Can I have that back? Can I have my body?
Watch out for my body rolls. Watch out for my body rolls. Hi kicks. Hi kicks. This is how we do it.
All right. Now I'm fashionable.
Bobblehead, she be. No, I'm a door hon.
She was like a Lego to stick. Oh, big. Oh, big yarn, Fia. Hello. What are you doing?
And a baby. Oh, pat the nose for the baby. You know. Can I have a kiss?
She's like, no, no kisses. Fia usually wakes me up with a, with a licky on my nose,
but she hasn't been able to do that.
Why are you looking around so much?
You got places to be. You got places to be, momma.
A boop just knew it. I have boopa just knew it. Boop.
He's just like headbutting me. He's so cute. He's so cute, miss ma'am. Where's Boomi?
Oh, he's, he now, he's in the bed, guys. He's in the bed that I put on the ground like an hour
ago, waiting for him to settle down into. And he's asleep in the bed.
Toss this cheese slice on her face. You want me to throw a slice of cheese on my paralyzed cat?
No. My head still looks really big. It's fine. Don't worry about it.
Boomi's, Boomi's literally right by my feet right now. I don't even want to say his name
because then I'll wake up. If I leave the room, he won't leave the room with me.
Boomi as I could, he has his moments.
I just looked down. He's like freaking, he's knocked. Could you see me when I,
Theo, who are you looking at? What do you, I think she just realized that there's like a shelf
above her? She's like, oh, what the heck?
Theo's looking up at Boomi and she's like, can I get some attention too?
Hey, let's go over here. Why don't we?
Hey, how you doing? Ignore the stuff that's scrolling.
Just pay attention to me and you.
Yeah, you turned on the music. How's it going?
Are you city east? Yeah.
I'm so epi. I have not been sleeping well because I've been up. I'll wake up a lot just to check
on for you. I'm very epi right now, but I'm going to wait until Elias is on. But hey, how are you guys doing?
I know it will get you guys happy.
I mean, I really wish I had a popsicle right now. That would be crazy. That would, that would be great.
I can't wait for the blue website.
My ears have appeared. I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh, don't worry about that.
I forget how to turn into a white woman again.
Oh, hi.
Whoa, isn't it crazy when I take off my Tantoggle? How pale I actually ended up looking.
That's quite funny.
I know my body is tan, but it's fine. It just looks dark.
Yeah, it's got better hanging out with you guys.
I unplugged my camera. Pay my bills. What do you mean?
With one click you can be a white woman. That is, that is something funny.
I'm starting to get used to the blue eyes.
Well, then I look devious with the red eyes.
The blue eyes, I know it looks like, I don't know, again, because the layering is messed up on both,
but you can't really notice it as much on the blue one as on the red one.
She can now summon blue eyes, white woman, in attack mode.
Oh my god, blue eyes, white woman. Oh no. Oh no. Oh no. Hold on. Oh, hi for you.
Where?
What's up, lady? What's up, lady? Whoa.
I'm just pulling up another outfit. Oh, sick. I didn't know I could do that.
So if I get rid of this,
hold on. Sorry. I like sometimes I'll toggle stuff and I don't know where I put the toggle.
Oh, but ignore that red ring.
Aha. And then, and then, and then, I don't remember where I put any of my toggles.
What the hell?
Bro, sometimes my toggles just get messed up because I have a toggle to make my ears darker
and they're not working. I hate it here. Well, I'm just gonna beat you then.
No, take me back to Paradise City where the grass is green and the girls are brown.
Sorry. Okay, I just, I just won't have ears then in my, I look very gyaru with my blush.
Please, please, please, please, please. Where is it? Where is it? Oh, I found it.
Meow. Yippee.
Imagine if I was this short.
What the heck did I do? Something like, I don't know why, but
this went like full screen. Go, stop. OBS went full screen and I can't get out of it.
I don't know how. I'm not strong enough.
Oh, police, animal experts investigate Chupacabra remains near Sterling.
Sterling PD is the, sorry, I'm reading the things, Chupacabra.
Okay, so they just talk it up to it.
Whoa, new background. I'm getting stuff unlocked.
What the hell? No, I don't want to play again, please. Well, I do. I will play this again.
Can I quit? Thank you.
All right, because I can't see the chat. I just want to see the chat.
Oh, my God, my back pocket size. I got a pocket, I got a pocket for us.
Here he gets a Bethany size.
I would agree with that. Oh, showing a little leg.
I like a casual outfit. Thighs. Oh, ignore me that I'm just thighs.
I don't know if I can change anything about this outfit, can I? I don't think this outfit has any toggles.
I don't think it does, no.
Yeah, it's just simple. It's a simple, cute outfit and I like it.
I think I'll probably use this outfit a lot when I'm not, like, I don't know.
I just like the outfit. I wish you could see the belly button more, though. Can't really see the belly.
But yeah, this is just a booth outfit. It's very cute.
You find your lack of feet disturbing? Well, sorry about that.
I'm sorry, Amigo. Oh, wait, hold on. Let me, while I'm waiting, I'm going to fix that.
Sometimes there are shadows that you can't really see.
I can't tell if that's the right one.
Sorry, I'm looking at my legs and I'm trying to get the lace off.
There we go.
Oh, it's a sour hole model for a second. Just like jump scare you. Kind of terrifying, but it's fine.
Now I'm looking for something so I can save that.
Okay, I fixed it, so now that shouldn't do that anymore. I think I fixed the, I hope I fixed the
ring being there. Wait, you do have legs. Well, I have like that much leg.
No feet. Guys, it's just an outfit. They usually don't make the entire model. They
usually just do it because most people, you don't see the bottom of models. That's why the bottoms
of models are so usually like not super detailed or like super designed because people, you barely
see them. So sometimes it just like, you can really, it honestly makes way more sense for
everybody to have half body models rather than full body because you never see the freaking full
body. Like it's usually like, I'm up here like this. Hey, guys, welcome to my stream. That's
why it's always important when you're with vtuber designs is that all the attractive things are
on the top and then maybe some interesting things are at the bottom. What if she was cool and I am
cool and casual? What do you mean? I'm always cool and casual. I'm always keeping it cool,
kid. Always keeping it cool. Okay, let me redirect. Thank you for spending time with me today, by the
way. You guys took a lot of the stress off and it was nice to have Fia be next to me so I can keep
an eye on her and you guys could also just like keep an eye on her for me. Hey, I gotta go. Can
you guys watch my cat? Yeah, I appreciate you guys' support so much. It helps a lot with the bills
and stuff. So I appreciate you big time.
Uh, I think, oh my goodness.
Aw, thank you, Miru. Thank you so much. Yeah, I'm gonna get some rest. I'm gonna
try to have her use the litter box before I go to bed because it can be a little bit harder for
her when she's like this. So I really have to hold her up and just hope that stuff comes out and she
doesn't get messy. But you know, I'll do anything for her. I love her so very much. I would move
heaven and earth for my baby Fia to be okay. So thank you so much for the $50 tip. A lot of the,
like again, I said it earlier, but like I do stream full time. All of your tips,
some people think that it's 80% goes to be a lure and 20% us. I get 80% of my earnings
and 20% goes to be a lure. And then 80%, I stream full time. So it literally, it goes back to me
and it goes back into my projects, like I have a project I'm working on and I commissioned.
But I hope you guys enjoy at some point. And like the art I get, and also just like paying
my bills and taking care of my cats and feeding me. So thank you for allowing me to live.
I appreciate you for allowing me to live.
All the tips go directly to Shibi's rant, taking care of Fia.
Yeah, I love you for being honest, but yeah, like we're pretty transparent and honest.
But if you slay management with a big, must be played again, 100%.
Now I love my management team. They're great. They're cool peoples. They really are. They're
very helpful. They literally just let me do whatever I want. And then when I need help, they're
just like, do you need help with this? And I'm like, yes, please. Do you need me to make this
thumbnail? Yes, please. Do you need me to put up your waiting room for you because you're with
your cat? Yes, please. Stream elements, yeah, stream elements. This takes away a lot less than
YouTube. And then the fans, Lee, I'll be getting 100% of when I start. I mean, the blue website.
But I'll be, honestly, I think people are going to think I'm going to do like crazy stuff. I'm
probably just going to, you guys saw, if you go there, you'll see what I'm going to be doing.
I'm tired and I'm rambling right now. I'm trying to see, I don't think she started yet.
I wanted to throw some sweet, sweet stuff at her.
Come on, let's wait. Let me double check because I'm like, was that sometimes my stuff doesn't
load properly? Oh.
Ooh, she's doing a vampire made ASMR?
Oh my.
Wait, but it's a member. Oh, that's why I can't read into it. Was I gifted a membership?
Why am I able to watch this? Okay, well, I have to read somebody else then.
I might have must have been hit with a membership because I'm like, wait, why can I see this,
but let me read into it. Oh, I'm going to read Pippa. I've never read a Pippa before. I'm
terrified to read Pippa, but I'm ready Pippa. Everybody say hi to Pippa. Just do, just scream
mortis. Just be like, mortis, mortis, mortis. Just do that. Thank you.
I'm sorry. Oh my God.
Thank you, Dr. Adon. Thank you. Thank you so much. Me too. I hope she recovers soon. It will take
some time, but she's tough. She's been through it before. She's a tough kitty. She's the toughest
kitty I know. Her and Reina are very tough. Reina especially. She's like a bag of old bones.
She just like flies around my house. But thank you guys so much. Oh, speaking of the devil,
she just hopped on my lap. So yeah, read her and say mortis. Okay. Bye. Bye. Later.
And you guys around stinky.